[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
a
d
[Music]
n
w
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
oh
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walked right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
board 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar is going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God what an armag
in just like the fields in the champion
chess tour our commentary Trio is
trimmed to two there are only two
players left in each and every division
here in the first leg of the Champions
chest St the Chess Masters I'm Robert H
alongside me is Grandmaster David Howell
David we're going to miss Tanya today
but how excited are you for the action
I'm super excited I'm gutted Tanya has
abandoned us but there's still so much
chess to look forward to and uh who else
I mean who would I rather follow these
games with Robert nobody other than you
um yeah I'm looking forward to it today
we take a pause from division one but
division two division three so much on
the line so much still to play for and
some household names well if Magnus
Carlson didn't think he had a long
enough vacation it's extended by a day
because we will not have any action in
division 1 today but let's remind
everybody of who is left standing we
started with eight participants in the
top division and now it is just Ali Raza
fua who came back from the losers
bracket to face Magnus Carlson Magnus
will have two lives in the Grand Final
but Ali R of fuia David he's been quite
impressive as he's been able to regain
his form Alara after a tough start to
division one bounced back made his way
all the way through the losers bracket
and uh that's some priz a match against
Magnus Carlson he will have to beat him
twice tomorrow if he wants to win the
Hess I mean chessable Masters but uh he
can do it ala has been in sparkling form
the last few days it's all about how
will he prepare how will he be able to
do against Magnus Carlson the number one
player in the world so Two Can Play That
Game but two will be playing in division
2 as well because we started uh with
division 1 that's been our main focus
we're going to be in division 2 and
division three which is where we see
these two players left standing Alexis
Sera and Alexander gusik but David look
at how many names are on this graphic so
many appear here that we can barely see
them what a bracket that is it's a just
a beast there it's ginormous this
bracket but this is the winners bracket
we started with eight in division 2 and
uh that has been whittled down uh at
least eight in the quarterfinals but
that has been whittel down as you
mentioned and in the winner semi-finals
it was s uh and kishuku triumphed they
met in the winners final SRA knocked him
out 3-0 a uh walkover pretty much but
grishuk has made his way back he's
aiming for Revenge today robt down but
not out was Alexander Guk he took down
Alexander bortnik in the losers final
bortnik a streamer content CR very
strong grandmas from the Ukraine he
actually lost his first match and still
was able to make his way through to the
losers final before bowing out to
Alexander grishuk so we have a rematch
in division three it's Alexi Ser versus
Alexander grishuk David these two
players uh they come from different
Generations but nowadays they're quite
neck and neck and as we see on at least
on paper Alexis tono with the overall
head-to-head lead 7 to2 with one draw
are you surprised by that
well uh I'm not surprised that Alexa s
is so highly rated on chess.com in Rapid
chess he's the European Champion uh Not
Just In classical in quicker formats too
and there we see him on camera I am
surprised though Robert as you mentioned
that he has such a big upper hand
against uh his former compatriot uh
Alexander grishuk grishuk is so
experienced uh so Wy so cunning such
deep chess understanding but it's the
new generation it's youth prevailing so
far and that head-to-head was influenced
by the other day and grishuk will have a
score to settle I think this is actually
going to be much closer now uh that the
stakes are higher SRA he's not going to
have it all his way as he did just a
couple of days ago so um yeah a lot to
look forward to grishuk is one of my
favorite players um especially invested
in this one grishuk is a favorite of the
masses because he always brings those
quips and his entertaining style to
interviews and also the chess board so
that's what's happening in division
three let's also dive into division 2
because there is so much on the line
here in the second division the winner
will take part in the top division in
the next event also win a cool
$115,000 and just like division 3 there
are a lot of players that are have their
names on this graphic 16 entered only
two remain and as we look towards the
top it's been the Vincent kimer show
from the start he took down Peter Sidler
he blanked him he then beat Jeffrey
Jeong he also was able to defeat
Benjamin Bach and he will face leavon
aronian who he came from the bottom side
of this bracket he also got off to a
blistering start and even defeated
vladislav artv David we've seen artv
thrive in the top division beating
magmus Carlson in the 2023 season but
leavon was too much for him then we saw
kimer take down leavon throw him to the
losers bracket but just like in division
3 that player was able to continue and
make it back to the Grand Final it's
leavon aronian it's Vincent kimer David
what do we make of this I like the
Symmetry I've got to admit Robert it's
another Clash of generations Vincent
still a teenager Levon he's been around
he's done it all before uh it's also a
rematch just as in division three and uh
Vincent will start out as the favorite
he has two lives remaining Levon is the
one who needs to win twice now in two
separate matches Levon also has to
overcome that setback of having lost to
Vin earlier in the event but uh he's
capable as we know leonan he's a bit of
a magician he uh depending on his form
can surprise everyone um so I think this
one's also going to be close and on
paper the stats show it it's hard to
separate the two it's certainly is and
David sometimes we get by with a Little
Help from our friends neither of these
two had to play against Hikaru Nakamura
or Anish giri division two is just full
of powerhouses so Hikaru he bowed out
early he won a single match he lost two
of them he was gone and niri he won a
couple matches but then lost to Benjamin
Bach and it was leavon ronian who
stopped Benjamin because otherwise this
would have been Vincent against the
Dutch Grandmaster Benjamin buck so it
just goes to show how strong the second
division is as
well all three divisions as we're
getting used to now Robert it's pretty
much a who's who of uh of Chess I mean
all generations taking part all ages uh
kind of players from all over the world
it's really really nice to see and we're
getting unique matches I mean nowhere
else will you see a uh head-to-head
against Vincent between Vincent kimer
and Levon aronian H yeah I just can't
wait for the chest to start in a just in
a few minutes well before we get to the
moves let's talk about some of the
numbers because these two they did
square off the other day Vincent kimer
had the upper hand and that's why the
overall record is in Vincent's favor but
as we talk about division 2 appearances
continuing from a season ago leavon he
does have more experience and it's not
just because he's 41 years old he's just
been playing in more of the Champions
chestor
events yeah he's played in plenty of
those Champions chess tour events he's
played plenty over the board throughout
his career in Rapid hence his higher uh
feed rating than Vincent but of course
the youngster catching up here we see
Leon aronian in action in one of his
trademark characteristic uh flamboyant
shirts uh he's got Style on the board
he's got style whenever he plays chess
and uh a big big fan favorite and nice
to see him having such a success Robert
despite uh kind of yeah not going to
call him uh being a veteran here but at
least relatively compared to his young
opponent today here's a lot of
experience a wealth of experience and he
does have that fantastic style I know
that Danny wrench is a huge fan of lons
and well we do have Danny to help
explain what's about to happen and
what's been going on in division two and
three so why don't we we let everyone
hear it from Danny
himself the year-long Champions chess
tour consists of four main online events
and one live final each event will begin
with a playin tournament open to all
Grand Masters and top finishers from
qualifying events 69 players from the
playin will be joined on the second day
by the four qualifiers from the previous
Tour event match play with 73 players
will then determine placement across all
three divisions division play then
commences with 6 days of Double
Elimination Brackets the last players
standing are your winners the winner of
division 1 qualifies directly to the CCT
finals the winner of division 2 secures
a spot in division 1 at the next Tour
event while the winner of division 3 is
guaranteed at least a spot in division 2
in each event players also ACR points
for the season long leaderboard the
final standings will decide who joins
our division one winners at the year end
CCT live finals each regular season
event will feature a whopping
$300,000 prize pool while the final
eight players will battle it out for
their part in half a million dollar in
prizes at the final that's $1.7 million
up for grabs in the 2024 Champions chess
tour so tune in and watch all the action
as the best chess players in the world
compete to be crowned the next CCT
Champion if you heard Danny's words it
means you're already here and it means
you want to see who will take the Lion
Share of these prizes the prize pool in
division 2
$93,500 first place winning 15K second
10K and the points that is all important
David the those leaderboard points they
will play a part in who makes to the
season and finals yeah the points could
be essential every Point matters not
only does the winner of division 2 get
50 points they also qualify for the next
Champions chess T event Division 1 where
they're guaranteed a bunch of points as
well so there's so much at stake
actually a huge difference both in terms
of uh the cash reward and uh the points
just based on these next few games and
we see them there on our cameras both
look ready to rumble Levon aronian he's
been playing super fast throughout this
event uh just pretty much playing Blitz
despite the rapid format Vincent Robert
has been so so impressive he's been one
of the kind of breakout stars of the
last few years and only getting better
day by day just 19 years old is Vincent
kimer he's assured of at minimum a
$10,000 payday so Vincent the best of
his chest is ahead of him but he needs
to bring his best today if he's going to
take down the Wy veteran lean Ronan well
speaking of Wy veterans David it's
Alexander
Gish yeah as I mentioned uh I love
grishuk just his style his Charisma um
he does tend to get in time Trouble Over
the board that could be a bit of a
hindrance for him today but uh something
that I think a lot of our viewers uh
will empathize with yeah
grishuk he yeah understands chess so
much better than most players um yeah I
can't wait to follow those games Robert
I just saw out the corner of my eye on
the camera as well uh just uh showing
his age with some tech issues there but
we'll be back with the players very very
shortly that was quite amusing I'm glad
that we didn't expose that to the world
but yeah he was definitely pointing to
his phone maybe doing some fair play
checks uh that was funny so the games
will begin in just a couple of minutes
now David I guess I have to put you on
the spot it's just the two of us what do
you expect in these matches do you think
that the players who are coming from the
winners bracket and thus have two lives
do you think they'll just keep on
sailing and win their titles or do you
think leavon or Gish who have come back
from the dead from the losers bracket do
you think they can land two match
victories in a row that's a tough call
Robert uh yesterday I backed experience
I back to Yano pesi to triumph over a
couple of youngsters that was not the
case in the end it was youth that
prevailed today this Clash of
generations it's the younger player in
both division 2 and three who have those
extra lives so even if they're pegged
back and kind of lose that first match
maybe that extra energy uh from being a
bit younger will help if it does end up
being a marathon so I do feel Vincent
kimer today big favorite I think Alexi s
a bit of a favorite there I've learned
from yesterday Robert with my prediction
uh always back these youngsters this new
guard uh how about yourself what are you
expecting it's hard to bet against
Vincent kimer under any circumstances
but when he has two lives the lonians
one I do think that leavon has serious
chances he has the style to get under
people's skin like he just plays very
quickly he plays confidently he takes
risks and you tend to believe him
because he's one of the highest rated
players in chess history so for leavon
ronian and Vincent kimer I actually
think that this one uh really depends on
who gets that first game if leavon wins
game one I think Vincent could be in
trouble even though he has those two
lives there's a lot going on in Vincent
room right now I can see the clock in
the top left corner the games the
countdown has begun about to start any
moment uh is the writing on the wall I
mean that's some funky wallpaper but
Vincent ready to go and Lev on two he's
back in his chair we're going to see
liftoff any moment now and looks like
Vincent will start with the white pieces
Robert he'll be eager for a fast start
in this one he certainly will you do not
want to lose with the white pieces start
giving your opponent that confidence
boost and we have D4 action is underway
here in division two of the ches Masters
and by the way I like that uh artwork
behind leavon is he the king is he
trying to uh say that he also is uh
painting he is you going to at least do
art on the chessboard David H he's a bit
of an artist when he gets in the flow uh
let's hope for Lebon sake the black king
isn't the one toppling over uh on the
board at least but in the meantime it's
the grunfeld defense
and uh actually a rare a rare guest in
aonian repertoire not his usual stuff
and wow look at this maximum Central
tension already this I've been playing
this opening my entire career my entire
life but this is a rare position I've
got to say uh just on this last move
black initiating the chaos look at that
black Bishop the Assassin the Archer
from afar and already the fact that
Vincent's PA is not a good sign for
white if he wants to kind of bail out
he'll start taking Pawns in Center you
shouldn't take the C Pawn as you
mentioned there's tension along the
diagonal take this Pawn instead and this
will guarantee a bunch of exchanges and
we'll see the kind of the skeleton of
the grinfeld form in a moment white has
more Central pawns white has uh a really
nice structure there but black has
activity and will aim to erode chip away
at White's center from afar so um
interesting mind games for me Robert um
I haven't been following Levon too
closely in this event but uh definitely
not
of his normal repertoire a bit of a
surprise for Vincent at these early
stages and that's what leavon has shown
a willingness to do he doesn't just play
in one style in one opening he is
venturing into new territory and that
makes it difficult to pin him down to
prepare for and this queen on D5
normally we don't like our Queens out in
the center of the board because they get
kicked by pieces but look at what leavon
is doing he's actually trading the
Queens liquidating so David we're
getting the start of a grunfeld ending
here I believe King takes Queen you can
use your King as a weapon in the end
game so you don't have to Castle it but
what do you make of these types of
positions are they more up Vincent or
leavon
allei I would say Vincent despite his uh
Tender Years he uh he's really really
good in strategic positions shout out to
Peter Leo as well his longtime coach
who's uh given this kind of solid
foundation to Vincent's play who's uh
kind of taught him how to kind of
maximize how to grind in these types of
end games and um yeah leevon you would
associate him with more active play
potentially Robert so with the Queens
off the board unlikely to be any direct
tactics uh minimal attacks despite the
white King sitting in the center I think
now Vincent will activate that white
Rook there we go the reason for viewers
at home uh that he took with the King
was to connect his Rooks get that white
Rook out of H1 as quickly as possible
now the white king might just slide back
and uh at least he's kind of castled but
uh yes a superficial Castle but his
King's actually far better place than it
would be off in the corner you don't
need to keep the king too safe you're
really active um as I mentioned earlier
I've got a lot of experience here mostly
from the black side and it's not that
much fun uh compared to a normal
grinfeld I think Vincent's trying to
suck the joy out not for us we're going
to enjoy it nonetheless Robert but for
Leon aronian well leavon just put his
rook in line with the white king so it's
clear he wants to push this Pawn to E5
as the D4 Pawn is pinned and David I
know you've got experience on the black
side and when you play these top Grand
Masters they don't miss simple ideas
like that but what they do accomplish is
they take control over open files and
restrict your pieces uh this situation
on the queen side is one where white
already has the Rooks connected as you
mentioned the Rooks can take control
over long open files and it's Bishop on
F4 as long as it can't be blockaded it
stops a black Rook from getting to a
defensive score like B8 so I have to
agree with you that it isn't Pleasant to
have this type of position from the
black side side if your opponent knows
what he's doing does Vince him
David that's the big question uh he's
paused and a bit of an odd moment to
pause because as you mentioned Robert a
huge threat on the board Pawn to E5 um
it might not necessarily win material
but it would break Black's open uh
Black's position open and yeah the white
king will start to sweat so there's only
two moves I see two candidate moves uh
in this position either you slide back
with the white king just kind of
automatic the autopilot move or you put
the white Rook on C5 position it on a
slightly vulnerable square but uh just
to control Black's potential counterplay
um you mentioned knowing what you're
doing often the top players they'll be
able to feel out the position the
structure they want the pieces they want
to keep on the board or exchange but uh
OD slightly odd at least to see Vincent
think for so long already over two
minutes down on the clock and it's still
basically uh the early stages he was the
one who chose this variation there we go
one of the moves happens Rook to C5 U
very logical move but slightly slower
start uh do you think the nerves are
playing a role here or just trying to
find his bearings I think there are
nerves because he's got a chance to
qualify for the top division and he's
playing leavon Ronan who is a trickster
who doesn't mind bluffing and you ask
all of the top players about leavon they
say they can't always tell when he's
deep in preparation or just playing off
the cuff and it's just because he has so
much experience and he's beaten all of
the best players on the planet look up
his head-to-head with Magnus Carlson In
classical chess he's taken him down so
many times in his career so leavon is he
in his preparation is he just rolling
with the punches as the moves happen I
do think he's in prep David I have to
say this looks like a standard position
from the black side and once again he is
trying to open up ideas with E5 by
moving his Bishop to G4 and also he's
connected his Rook so I like what Leon's
doing no problems with what Vincent has
done but David the clock that is where I
feel concerned for Vinton is at some
point he will need to speed up need to
speed up and he will need to stay
vigilant on this move because there are
some tactics in the air if white were to
be careless and play a move like H3 uh
kind of asking a question of Black's
light Square Bishop then black would
just trade off on F3 and look at the
white Rooks they're actually lined up on
uh dark squares Knight takes D4 here I
think would be a killer uh at least
giving black a big big advantage and now
Bishop takes D4 both the white Rooks are
forked double attacked and Leon aronian
would suddenly win on the spot so
Vincent needs to get one of his Rooks to
a safer Square um this is what to avoid
and once you know what to avoid it makes
it easier to figure out what you want to
do instead he puts his Rook on C1 so
that tactic doesn't work black can
potentially uh get a rook for two pieces
but you want to keep your minor pieces
on the board right now and level aronian
I'm going to say Robert because he
doesn't uh kind of uh he doesn't throw
out the gfell too often I do fear for
him unless he's able to get something
concrete if White's able to keep this
bind the strong Pawn on D4 uh then I
think black might be suffering long term
so uh yeah kind of pros and cons Black's
very very active but you need to
continue to be energetic uh in this type
of position and not easy to do just kind
of taking your foot off the P off the
pedal off the gas and you could just be
in for a lot of torture later on um
going to say I'm favoring white here
slightly Robert how about you I agree
and I think you're speaking from
experience having the black side of the
grunfeld in this end game uh you know it
is favorable for white who has the
activity but black in the long run has
outside pawns that potentially you can
use to your advantage so while leavon
sits in for his first major think of the
game why don't we zoom out because we
also have the Grand Final in division
three Alexis s versus Alexander Guk you
see that on the right hand side of the
screen and oh what a different type of
position we have there apparently Guk is
just crushing
him wow what has happened on that board
look at the evaluation bar on the right
uh side of your screens everyone white
is apparently just winning despite the
fact it's level material and it's purely
because of the paity of Black's pieces
look at the black queen on the uh kind
of left line on B8 there so far
separated from her king that's always a
red flag in any chess position if you're
Queen's that far away she'll never
participate in the defense and you might
just get checkmated grishuk turning on
the style um I've got to say Robert as
well just below the board I see his
rapid rating that is so deceptive
Alexander grishuk is a 27 2800 player
he's not a 2648 at rapid no matter uh no
matter what and uh yeah he's just got a
clear-cut plan White's going to throw
the F Pawn forward white is going to go
for San's King and yeah dramatic
dramatic start to division three over
there um I mean it's just a glorious
position right now for white um s blocks
up that pawn push that I was mentioning
Robert but the problems are longterm
here and white hasn't sacrificed
anything normally to get a position like
this you might even give up a whole
piece I mean just to go on the attack
but here the material is even the black
queen on B8 the black Rook on A8 they're
not participating and you like to say
when the king and queen are divorced
that can cause problems the queen needs
to be on a square like F7 to help ensure
the king's safety so what would I do
here if I were uh Gip I'd be looking at
a rook lift I'm not even sure which Rook
Rook C3 over to the king side Rook F3
just scoot it on over to G3 or H3 I feel
like some of these moves are extremely
natural but I know from experience David
that sometimes you play the obvious move
and the engine immediately criticizes
you so I would be looking at Queen H5 a
rook lift but perhaps there's something
better do you see anything that is less
Brute Force than a move like Queen to H5
and a rook
LIF question Robert and I think here
yeah if I were grishik I would be facing
the exact same dilemma look at him kind
of shaking his head on the camera kind
of counting calculating he's spending
too much time because they too many
attractive moves you mentioned a bunch
of them Queen H5 looks so uh tempting
Rook to F3 I like maybe a bit more than
Rook C3 because then you can kind of
switch to the queen side King side
depending on uh where your uh opponent
starts playing yeah but essentially you
just have to trust your instincts and
move grishuk um the one thing that did
trip him up I feel from uh the kind of
first match against s um when I played
through those games it was the clock it
was his time handling and S he's not
going to be shy about hustling on time
if he needs to Black's position is so
desperately bad um but grishuk he's got
too many choices he's not going to
calculate a Checkmate here I think we
were both trying to work out whether
there's anything direct grishuk look at
him talking to himself now he's thinking
the same but he's just got a move he's
still going to be better like you said
the eval bar might switch but who who
cares he just have to keep time up your
sleeve for later um as the feature chat
say it is dominance this position but
that will change if the clock keep but
under four minutes now this is the story
of Bish's
career it really is and if you give
black a few turns Rook F7 Knight f8 get
this bishop out of here like it's not
like it's a complicated plan from
Black's perspective and that's why I
think you and I are agreeing that white
needs to act fast and sometimes haste
makes waste but I would not pause before
I played a move like Queen to H5 but you
can tell by gish's face right now he
he's a poker player but I don't think
that he has a poker face at the moment
he's like where is it how do I actually
go after my opponent and he has yet to
move David he is down four minutes so to
conduct an attack from here it's not
that obvious he needs to act fast he
needs to just move stop calculating uh I
mean this has been the problem of my
career as well time issues especially I
notice when you have a pleasant
advantage and kind of your Spidey senses
are tingling you know in the back of
your mind you're winning and it's
frustrating if your opponent uh kind of
sets up defenses like this and there's
no obvious breakthrough but um that's
where the top players the Magnus
Carson's the hikara Nakamura of the
world they just trust their instincts
they just set a trap eventually he
decides upon uh Knight to A5 Robert and
multi-purpose move that actually not on
my radar but I love
it I I think that was the move I'm gonna
quickly look I'm gonna go back a half
step and put on the that was the best
move by far Knight A5 so Alexander gruk
he spends quite a lot of time a move
that you admitted I admitted I wasn't
looking in that direction I'm looking at
the king side he says my knight isn't on
its best Square it can hop back to C4 to
ask questions of this bishop on D6 it
also freezes this B Pawn you definitely
don't want to see this Knight land on C6
to hit this queen on B8 and oh the move
Rook F7 played by S that's a pretty
Natural Choice but I think that this
Knight David can wrap around to C4 maybe
he's just going to keep it here forever
and say black is stuck you don't
actually have an active
plan and uh I think again this is great
for explain to everyone who isn't
familiar with grishuk his style he's a
perfectionist and uh that's a very good
thing in chess but it's a kind of
double-edged Blade perfectionism in
Rapid chess can backfire long term and
there we see Queen to G4 he's playing on
both flanks um I like it Robert I would
have also liked the consistent kind of
Knight C4 it felt like he was playing on
that side of the board but he's looking
at both flanks uh he's keeping black
honest and already traps the Black
Knight is frozen cannot move because the
White Knight would leap into B6 this is
almost zuk Swang I've got to say black
can barely touch a single Pawn a single
piece but it's all about the clock gisho
can he hold his nerves Pawn to B6 look
at s on the camera he's walked into
another KN Fork Knight d8 just wins the
game on the spot
oh oh my gosh David I love this game
this is a night's dance and he he
repeats this is that old school Russian
training that if you can repeat you have
to do it and then only afterwards will
he take this Rook but if he doesn't take
this rook and finds whatever better move
exists in the position I'm done I just I
won't be able to talk anymore I'll be
speechless that would be sadistic not
even snacking on a free exchange here
free material he does eventually take
and a good decision to play that move
quickly but uh yeah so classy just so
classy Robert when it all comes together
for grishuk I mean there's no one better
to watch simply white now has moves like
Queen to H5 check you either win the H7
Pawn or you sneak in Behind Enemy Lines
to the E8 Square um Rook lifts still
look really tempting right now um yeah I
mean Rook to F3 Rook to G3 there's
something is going to collapse he does
deliver a check first but s you can see
on the camera he's trying to keep his
Poker Face this time but the occasional
Flinch he's not enjoying this at all he
knows he's just been outclass in this
game and uh we have a real match in our
hands in this one if Gish takes the
first win Sano won all three games
between these two in the Winner's final
it was a 3-0 sweep and now it looks like
grishuk has a chance to get out to a hot
start but he does need to watch his time
we spoil winning positions regularly
when we don't have enough time to
calculate I am keeping an on the other
board and I also keeping eye on this
Rook on F3 sliding over David at this
stage I do think that g has everything
under control The Rook is coming over
for the attack and it's just a matter of
time before the black king side falls
apart feels like it's getting closer but
they do say that uh good positions don't
win games good moves do so he still
needs to land that killer touch uh that
final blow which is often the hardest
thing to do I'm expecting s to move the
black light squared bishop and just say
okay prove it um I'm sure there is
something in the position but uh it's
definitely gck with one minute who has
to uh find it he has to calculate um
what else black is totally stuck there's
literally nothing else to do s will move
his light Square Bishop but uh yeah look
at that clock one minute and Counting
big threat on the board Queen takes H7
and uh black again has to defend Retreat
the Knight what else Knight to f8 there
is no mate they say but this might be an
exception Robert this looks like there
will be a mating attack and while
grishuk is on the offensive I just want
to note that the other game it's about
to fizzle out so as we head back to our
bird's eye view we actually might catch
the end of the first game in division
two Vincent kimer and lvon Ronan they
had Bishops of opposite color well
Vincent he just left I don't know uh his
his clock is still ticking until the
draw is agreed as it has been so game
one in the books David a very fair
result looks like leavon handled himself
quite nicely Levon we were saying his
position was slightly uncomfortable he
needed to be energetic but he did find
the energy in the end and uh he was able
to trade off a bunch of pieces opposite
color Bishops do have that drawish
tendency probably the most drawn drawish
final position you'll ever see but yeah
will be a close match of course in
division two all eyes on this one Robert
and I think I found the Checkmate if
black does retreat Knight back to f8
White can actually take on F6 blow open
the black king
and start entering on the G file Rook to
G3 check will come the queen will come
into F7 s might just throw in the towel
and resign here um no way to defend it
is collapsing grishuk has found the
incisive path to Victory and it's a
lovely one H6 well this is clear
demolition time just Bishop takes H6 you
get rid of all of the shields in front
of the black's king that's pretty basic
and then for Black Knight F6 I think
Knight takes F6 check not nearly as OB
obvious but sacrificing a knight to get
at the black king it's just a quick
attack and David you're you're calling
it looks like grishuk had everything
under control from start to finish in
this game and that night maneuver and
look at SRA giving up H7 with Czech just
hoping that Guk will go wrong somewhere
that night maneuver Knight A5 I'm still
so impressed by that decision from Guk
yeah uh we were questioning it we
thought he was kind of uh playing it
fast and loose with the clock a bit
risky there but ultim he invested two or
three minutes k and that Knight maneuver
Knight A5 Knight C6 Knight d8 it was the
winning idea and look at this he's still
showing accuracy giving uh all the
checks now actually Rook to H7 might
lead to Checkmate a very well-known
pattern there Rook to H7 followed by
Queen to H5 and uh delivering the killer
blow um but or you can just take the
bishop if you don't want to risk it
kishik again perfectionism Robert it's
costing him a lot of time but uh it's
going to win him the game
we see off to the left of the board it
does say M5 Checkmate in five and Guk
finds it I me you see the accuracy right
next to his name there it says nearly
95% I don't know if where that 5% went
away from him because it seems like
every single turn that we saw was the
absolute best move and even in a
position where he could take a bishop
for free there's nothing wrong with this
move it's still winning for white he can
play Queen H5 and deliver checkm this
way he can play Bishop H6 and then take
on G7 but David just when Alexander Gish
is playing like this I mean this there
are even Magnus Carlson would struggle
against him as impr proven in the past
and Alexander grishuk he takes game
one how will play Gangster chess uh
we've all seen the kind of gangster
memes with grishuk uh with his really
charismatic interviews and that was just
a sparkling game
SRA he needs to recover that was really
one-sided that first game of course uh
he is uh he has two lives but grishik
Robert he's going to be a hard man to
stop in that form such a good start for
him so great to see and uh yeah I'm
going to say he's my favorite player for
a
reason he's unbelievable when he is in
form when he's not getting himself too
low in the clock Alexander gruk he seems
Unstoppable he leads 1 nil in division
three and in division two between leavon
ronian and the teenager Vincent kimer we
saw a peaceful result David two
extraordinarily different games totally
different in style in character there
Vincent tried to trade off pieces grind
down tried to obtain a small Advantage
but he was neutralized uh in the end
quite impressively by leevon aronian the
other game though it was just uh really
romantic chess it was reminiscent of
19th century chess just an attack brutal
Checkmate in the end and uh yeah I'm
hoping for more of the same often Robert
I find these matches kind of how they
start is an indicator of how they
continue and uh it's often hard to kind
of regain control for example if you're
s after just kind of reeling from that
defeat um the other one I'm sure will
come to life at some point Vincent kimer
and Leon aronian they're both too classy
not to start throwing things at each
other they'll get impatient eventually
but uh yeah a great start to this day
well we have seen Alexis s in division
one a year ago in the 2023 Champions
chessor he had some major upsets and he
beat ala fua in a match he was quite
powerful when he did make it into the
top division so s he's a familiar name
as you said European champion in
classical chess also in the quicker typ
controls he I think won the European
Team Championship so he had a great 2023
as his rating has risen to near 2700 but
the players that we have here in Vincent
kimer and Le aronian well over 2700
Vincent recently uh I think he went into
the top 20 players in the world and
leavon aronian the fourth highest rated
player in chess history so these two are
uh really stalwart of the game and David
as we get into this second game of the
match there's opening stages here whose
uh chances in the match do you like
better um I think it's just finally
poised finally balanced right now um
they're playing my favorite opening and
my favorite type of food Robert the
Italian and uh right now um yeah
interesting to see leevon aronian kind
of employ this opening I remember a few
years back uh as recently as 2019 or so
he was not known as an E4 player but now
dabbling in these types of setups with
white he's an expert of course from the
black side and um yeah interesting to
see this type of uh position arise we
saw fua employ something very similar
yesterday with success against Dennis
lazovic and uh yeah it'll take a small
kind of pause here here with a quiet
maneuvering phase uh there won't be any
fireworks yet but um I quite like the
fact that leevon is kind of playing
calmly here um of course we all know he
can change the pace at uh a moment's
notice he's so good at jumping on an
opportunity to kind of be dynamic but
right now yeah another quieter start to
this game how about yourself uh whose
chances do you favor after this opening
well I like how quickly Lavon is playing
and I know you like the opening because
it was your child
a pet line that everyone you said
criticized you for but leavon he
probably didn't because he's playing it
himself even as the years have passed
but this type of position I think
usually is Pleasant to play from the
white side you know exactly where your
pieces belong you try to get into uh
potential squares like F5 and black
often has to follow suit and reroute the
night but Vincent instead strikes in the
center so it's not impatience this is a
main idea but with a rook and a knight
staring at E5 sometimes you actually
drop a pawn in the center in these types
of lines so you need to be really really
careful before you make what looks like
a small Pawn Bush David it could have
huge consequences yeah uh you're right
Robert and already it's becoming
tactical I said it would be Karma just
pure maneuvering but uh maybe we can
show why white cannot get greedy here
and grab a porn some of the viewers
might be wondering okay there's tension
in the center you can win material greed
is good take on D5 uh but after
everything is traded off after Knight
takes Pawn here um if white takes on E5
this is a very well-known trick and
again pattern recognition for those who
are familiar with the Italian game
Bishop takes F2 Czech would regain the
material because white cannot take back
with the King simply loose pieces drop
off double attack Queen to F6 check so
um Levon or ronian he was calculating
this variation he didn't like it um yes
white could have dodged with the King to
H1 but then your king is always a bit
Airy a bit open so he chooses something
else instead and wow a really ambitious
move in the game from Levon aronian
Bishop to D2 this is based on the fact
you're not going to trade queens now on
the defile it's very KY though just
maximum tension uh Robert Levon trying
to embrace the moment and uh just
throwing the move back to his opponent
he is Agent of chaos leavon Ronan he
does not mind spicing things up he likes
those kind of combative positions and as
you said most importantly he's keeping
the Queens on the board one of the
threats and I'm saying that word lightly
was to have trade pawns on e4 and then
trade Queens off next that is
unavailable because there is a bishop in
the path of the black queen so I like
this decision you could also slide your
queen on over to C1 at some moment
because David we know how dangerous
sacrifices can be on this H6 square and
Vincent keeps thinking so I I once again
like how the opening is gone for Lon
yeah uh it's the clock time is a big big
giveaway here that Vincent isn't
entirely comfortable and um at least
less familiar with this type of position
than Leon aronian he does play Rooks E8
very healthy move I'm now expecting
Levon to kind of keep that tension Queen
to E2 Queen to C1 just kind of kg moves
and uh okay first Knight to G3 of course
another natural one um it's very hard
these positions again from my experience
with both colors with black you never
know when to trade when to push forward
in the center where to place your pieces
uh with white there's lots of obvious
kind of improving moves into black with
the choice black with the pressure on
but uh yeah now objectively balanced at
least Robin I just like the night on G3
and a note to everybody at home if you
play the Black side of these positions
the bishop on E6 is actually super
important to stop a white knight from
getting into F5 because we like to say a
knife on F5 it could be a dagger against
the a black king so be really really
careful before trading off too many
pieces and wow look at this move David
D4 that's is that impatience or do you
think that this type of move is Vinted
trying to claim some advantages of his
own I think a bit of both there um it is
impatient because you could have just
continued building up maybe moved the
black queen brought the uh black rook in
the corner to the center first before
deciding but it's also extremely
ambitious he's taking over the space
gaining uh ground in the center and
there are some threats Pawn takes C3 now
as a threat unleashing The Black Queen
the white D3 PA is a backward uh porn
it's a big big Target in the near future
but you have closed off you've kind of
cut the board in half with this decision
as Vincent kimer now if white is able to
just lock down the center or kind of uh
at least maintain it then White's
attentions will switch towards the king
side and it's going to be harder to
fight uh having the option you talk
about Pawn breaks uh Robert from time to
time and having the option to open
things up can can be a Gods end if
you're on the defensive uh now it's
going to be a locked structure for a
long time and uh totally different
nature of play so confident confident
move by Vincent but a bit of risk
attached that's how I see this last Mo I
like how you explained it cutting the
board in half because when we look at
Pawn chains where are the pawn chains B7
and A6 that's a pawn chain it's not what
I'm going to highlight in this position
but that is what a pawn chain is just
connected pawns so for those of you at
home who want to learn about Pawn chains
you attend to operate in the direction
of your Pawn chain white has a Pawn
chain towards the king side white would
like to get a knight to F5 black has a
pawn chain towards the queen side we may
see black further expand with moves like
B5 in the future and as David noted the
D3 Pawn is a bit tender in White's Camp
so this is what the players are aiming
for is you have to have full board
awareness that's for sure the case but
in this type of position white would
like to make a move like Knight H4 and
into F5 and white would be especially
pleased if this bishop leaves the board
because then the Knight can sink his
teeth into F5 without worrying about
being captured so right now leavon is on
the clock David maybe this is a good
moment for us as he Retreats his Bishop
just to zoom out to our bird's eye view
and see what's happening in division
three Robert we're so in sync he stole
the words right out of my mouth I've
just been peering over uh at the other
game which is uh just heating up this
moment and uh very different nature
again it's we have really contrasting
finals today in division 2 and three uh
wow grishik just widening his eyes there
um he's currently as black down a pawn
but the Queens are off and look at the
white king in the center of the board
s's King feeling the heat here not an
entirely happy piece but being up a pawn
he can even grab another Pawn on E5 um
this one's really imbalanced for a
coinless middle game this is one of the
Wilder variety um so much going on there
so much to unack Robert and the
evaluation bar slightly on white side
I'm also seeing the clock again very
different nature of position position
compared to the previous game but still
grishuk down four minutes already why
don't we dive in a little bit because
grook you know he's inching closer to
his laptop camera and the last one we
played E5 at first not receiving a
question mark But as the engine gets a
little bit deeper in thought it figures
out that was not the best move but I'm
being honest I'm looking I'm going to
open up what the best move is for white
David G4 and I think that does make
sense sometimes when we push flank pawns
it's like what are you doing my king is
unsafe in the center this king is not
actually unsafe here yes black has a
rook in line with it but you don't have
a follow-up you don't have too many
pieces attacking it so move like G4 just
to claim further space the E5 Pawn can
be captured in the near future and E4
was the second best move slightly lower
in value but around the same this makes
perfect sense to me David and you're a
hungry guy you like pawns do you like
that s has just snacked on a second Pawn
so that worst case scenario he'll be a
pawn to the good gimme gimme gimme uh
it's three pawns here Knight takes E5
and uh yes Gish can win one back but as
long as you have a material advantage
there we go he is down to one point now
but uh you can kind of bully the
opponent with the threat of exchanges
and uh Robert we mentioned the white
king it should be safe but still some
questions to answer if he can answer the
question of where to put the white king
if he does find a safe haven a refuge
for it then he should win this game uh s
but for now I do see compensation if uh
Black's other Rook Black's Knight the
dormant pieces on the queen side if
they're able to get into the game then
uh all of Black's Army will be playing
right now a retreat from s he's just
trying to consolidate gain time against
Black's Bishop the bishop is likely
going to move or it could be defended by
Black's Knight but either way yeah I
think SRA due to the fact some kind of
some Central squares are closed not all
the lines are open I he's going to be
enjoying this um we've talked about s in
the past Robert we covered him last year
in division one as you mentioned and
with white he's a totally different
animal um it's like uh yeah with white
he's just Unstoppable with black he
still has off days as we saw earlier but
uh this is where gri will need to kind
of earn his keep he needs to just hold s
the piranha at Bay in this game it's no
exaggeration to say that Alexis is world
class with the white pieces um you know
he has Stellar opening preparation you
see in this game here he's up a pawn his
King may seem like it's uh in some
trouble but the engine backs his play up
so Alexis s with the white pieces one of
the best players in the world Alexis s
with the black pieces as we saw in game
one that is where he has struggled so
why don't we leave these two to it as
Alexander Guk up a point in the match
but down a point in this position he
will have to find a way to stabilize and
he's looking away from the board I don't
think he's happy so we'll leave him to
his tough defensive tasks on the left
hand side of our screen David look what
we see on that board between leavon and
Vincent I believe that it was a
temporary peace Sacrifice from Vincent
just to regain it back with the little
baby
fork and uh I think we have to jump in
there Robert and maybe do a bit of an
action replay uh it was like New Year's
Eve just a small fireworks display
suddenly uh from Vincent kimer here
White had retreated a night to E2 but
look at the traffic jam of White's
pieces and this allowed Knight takes E4
as you mentioned uh that baby little uh
kind of firework display little
sacrifice here and a very common pattern
Motif for anyone who plays these Kings
porn openings now uh the Knight had to
be recaptured double exclamation mark
because it was a sacrifice but a double
attack now a fork and uh material
immediately regained and if we catch up
with the game it just looks like a
normal position it's as if nothing
happened but there was that moment of
drama Robert really really aware from
Vincent but it cost him a lot of time
look at the disparity six minutes
against three um yes it looks equal yes
it looks very symmetrical but I think
levon's going to be happy with uh how
this game is progressing and for leavon
you count your small pluses I think the
lead on the clock that's quite
significant but the small pluses I'm
talking about is look at this Pawn on C3
and look at this Knight on C6 this Pawn
takes away the forward progress from
that Knight for those of you who have
not heard me say it a million times I'll
go a million in one a pawn three squares
away from a knight dominates that Knight
because it takes away its forward leaps
so that's the good news for white and I
love that move David Bishop D5 trade on
your own terms if black takes white
takes back with the pawn hitting the
Knight and removing a guard of this Pawn
on E5 David I don't know about you but I
think this is getting really difficult
for Vincent all of a sudden getting
scary he might just have to go down a
pawn give up a pawn because if that
white Bishop is allowed to survive in
the center it's going to dominate
proceedings suddenly big questions to
answer um do you go Dynamic do you have
to sit passively and uh kind of just go
back and defend Bishop to D7 for example
Vincent's not going to be enjoying this
and only two minutes left this is why
Levon gets so much success just in
recent times with rapid chess he's so
instinctive so quick so tricky and I'm
not sure Vincent saw this one coming he
defends with Queen to D6 but this is
clumsy as well the black queen is going
to get hit by one white rook in the near
future and if Levon wants to be greedy
now he can indeed capture that black
knight and win the E5 Pawn so he's
actually support for Choice Levon he'll
slow down at this moment I'm wondering
whether you can just build keep the
tension Rook a to D1 there's some
tactics to calculate there um it's just
about whether you cash in early and take
a minimal Advantage a pawn up but black
would have the bishop pair or whether
you really try and maximize whoa Pawn to
B4 instead um threat after threat here
Robert I like it he is playing with
Force he doesn't want to just save and
passively say I have a slight Advantage
let me try to milk that he is saying I'm
actually creating a weakness on the
Queen's side white will try to play A4
in the near future after fixing the B
Pawn so David this is a quite strong
play when we talk about the principles
of a position the Knight on C6 can't go
anywhere this Pawn makes sure that the
the black Pawn on B5 can't go and then
A4 I not sure you can get away with it
yet maybe you flick in Bishop takes E6
but then A4 happens and black is on the
back
foot really classy there Le aronian a
lot of us wouldn't have been able to
resist the uh the gift the treat of a
free Pawn but instead he's just going to
have a solid uh positional Advantage you
call it Bishop takes Bishop pawns A4
this is why the Italian the Spanish
they're always slightly better for white
long term it's never much but it's
always a bit uncomfortable for black
it's because of that Dynamic with the
Black Knight on C6 misplaced and here we
go chipping away at Black's queenside uh
structure there um really classy play
three full minutes up and look at the
accuracy Levon flexing there 98% Robert
and uh it's yeah just looks like a
really Pleasant position turning it into
something more tangible that's the next
step um do you think he's going to win
this game uh do you think he's going to
be able to back up his strong play his
energetic play so far the speed that's
really what's sticking out to me and the
fact that he's pre-moving leavon aronian
doesn't really play all that much bullet
he's participating in bullet chess
championships in the past but he is
showing that he can get down and dirty
he can pre-move he can make sure that he
has more time on his clock than his
opponent and the rerouting of that
Knight that seems smart I kept talking
about how the Knight on C6 it was stuck
in place perhaps there are greener
pastures on a square like F4 but I do
think that leavon has very good winning
chances just because he's slightly more
active right now and the clock I know a
minute 30 seconds for these Elite Grand
Masters that is is really a ton of time
to them but sometimes you start Fring
you get nervous and you make mistakes
David yeah definitely unless your name
is Alexander Gish and uh you kind of
born with one minute on your clock but
uh yeah Vincent he'll be feeling the
heat but I think this trade of Bishops
he'll be also breathing a little sigh of
relief that the Knight is off that
horrible Square on C6 and uh maybe if we
zoom out of this temporarily just while
Levon invests a bit of time he still two
and a half minutes up uh the other game
still looks very chaotic uh SRA with 5
and a half minutes gisha with 1 and a
half minutes and big threats on the
board White's Knights are just lined up
they're attacked right now um what you
make of this Robert again it's it's kind
of this clock disparity on both boards
and very different nature of both finals
right now I'm looking at the board on
the right between Alexander grishuk and
Alexi S I mean Guk is down a pond but
his piece is are active but the look on
his face he does not look like a man who
is happy about his position he's
curiously trying to work through some
tactics hopefully they go in his favor
but he is down upon so I don't think he
truly believes in his chances and wow
San made a great move by the way forcing
off some of the material so leavon on
the left hand side he has the advantage
on the clock with white Alexi on the
right hand side very much the same David
who would you say has the better chances
to hold between V kimr who objectively
is not much worse but is in some time
trouble and Alexander grishik who the
engine says is worse but he has all this
activity I think I agree with the
evaluation but on the at least in this
regard at least Vincent kimer isn't
material down White's Advantage is about
the board uh is kind of a little bit
more activity there but also on the
clock um at least SRA has something to
work with has something to suffer for he
has a clear Pawn to the good and uh
often if you give the top players kind
of a theoretical Advantage something a
bit vague they'd rather cash in and turn
it into something they can cling onto
something concrete so I'm going to say
that s is happier than aonian but then
again Vincent's clock just every time we
go away seems to tick faster than ever
30 seconds suddenly and uh White's Rook
has infiltrated on the seventh rank both
of these games we should mention could
go in any direction all three results
possible um it's not the type of
position where
kind of you're suffering and suffering
and it could only be a draw Still Robert
which one do we dive back deeper into um
gish's jumping in with his Knights the
Black Knights on the right board uh so
tricky springing forward um meanwhile
Levon against Vincent it's dramatic on
the clock um W Rooks on the seventh rank
seventh heaven Robert I think we need to
jump in there with Leon aronian let's
dive back into our division 2 title
match it it's the grand finals Vincent k
he has two lives to leavon RS one that's
in this double elimination format and
look at leavon go he is playing for the
clock as much if not more so than he is
playing on the board H4 not for the
score but just to kick this Knight out
of the G6 and look at fiton making these
small mistakes David White's Rooks are
too active here and loose pieces may
drop
off I might have to Revis my opinion a
moment ago I said at least there's
nothing tangible here for Levon Aron and
Vincent could maybe consolidate with
some exchanges but he might just go down
a pawn uh the E5 Pawn is surely doomed
over the next few turns he's desperately
trying to trade off pieces um like you
said activity over everything here
and yeah it's now time for that
calculation phase shout out to KY for
for us right now H5 wow H5 and we're
live surely that wins a pawn the arrow
the blue arrow appears Robert only move
Knight to F4 I was going to ask of
course he finds it
kind but he found the first step what's
next does this KN have to continue going
in White's territory two seconds he
barely gets his move off he Retreats but
David now he is down upon pawn and
White's attack can rage on with Rook to
F5 slide that Rook out of there and
vacate the E5 Square for the night I
just don't believe in Black's King
safety nor do I believe in his
clock would be a really classy move it's
just a illusion White's King being weak
here yes there's going to be a check on
the background but white king has a nice
safe Square to hide on on H2 I don't
think you have to sweat too much about
keeping your King on that post uh so I'm
expecting Rook to F5 as well Rook to A1
would be another candidate move if you
really want to sh up your defenses but 4
seconds yeah Vincent he's got to go into
hustle mode he's got to try and swindle
leevon here but not easy when you have
no time to think suddenly his heart is
going to be racing uh so fast right now
he knows that he's up against it Levon I
think this is his chance if he wants to
kind of get that Grand Final reset he
needs to strike in this game and for
Vincent you know he's like squeezing the
mouse right now he's is he going to go
now is he going to go now you're just
waiting to see what leavon plays and
when he does it because Rook A1 is a
perfectly great good move Rook F5 the
same both of these are normal moves that
help white out king H2 is a third move
that comes to mind you may walk into a
pin but the check on the first rank is
no longer available so uh for Vincent
this is a stressful situation David I
don't envy him but leavon he's getting
down to 40 seconds himself those bullet
skills Levon there on the camera I think
for the first time in this match we see
him getting a bit Twitchy and uh what's
he going to play he needs to move 30
seconds it's a pure bullet scramble it
becomes more of a lottery than ever and
that would be such a shame for leevon
who's had the game under control uh for
such a long time he's got a move he's
Frozen Robert he spent a minute and a
half on this move does he realize the
urgency of the
situation come so Random I was looking
at his camera he wanted that followup so
he recognized that he was want to Rook
A1 but isn't he just dropping this Pawn
on C3 and fzy doesn't take it because B5
was also
lose the advantage is uh is maybe lesser
with Queens off the board wh piece is a
bit clumsy and big threat on C3 he's at
six seconds he's below Vincent on the
clock
this is go the attack Rook F5 Knight E5
so he gave up a pawn to go on the
offensive David this does not look easy
frankly for either side to play oh it's
two seconds against 8 seconds Vincent o
he's making moves with one second left
and uh at least blacks got his defenses
set up the black king Knight oh he
dropped a pawn and that's not just one
Pawn David that's two pawns at minimum
but look at leavon making sure he
doesn't drop a pawn F3 first and now we
get scoop up a second second White's
clearly winning that was the clock
Robert you called it blunders they do
happen uh when the clock ticks down and
you can autopilot Auto move pre moove
there uh this one if you're Lebon
aronian he's setting up on the seventh
rank but now a hit on the white rook in
the
Knight are we seeing more he's giving up
his KN but it actually is justified by
the engine what a sacrifice what
awareness from Levant to realize this
Knight is pinned and it's the black king
that's in danger but suddenly David the
white king oh H three though what a move
what a move white has so many pawns so
many check mating ideas and he just
trades off but he's not going to win the
H Pawn lean aronian it's the might of
Pawns against the powerful Black Knight
who's going to succeed here it's still a
lottery still all three results on the
table um leevon aronian I think it's
easier to play with pawns here Robert
you can just push push push uh one track
mind I think it's easier to play what
position I don't even know what black is
supposed to do you could give me a day
to figure this out I wouldn't know
because the Black Knight seems stuck the
white Pieces Just Shuffle about and at
some point there will be Pawn pushes but
don't rush that I think that's the key
here for leavon is he can't push his
Pawn legally at the moment and you don't
want to push G5 too soon because you
don't want to split your remaining Pawn
so not actually easy to end this
game he walks in with the white king be
careful the white King has no squares so
don't get checkmated but uh the might of
the pawns if he pushes the right Pawn
chooses the right moment he should be
winning he's calculating whether he can
play Pawn to E6 right now this is uh
kind of weird x-ray vision almost a pin
from the white Rook to that Knight but
Vincent three seconds he's got a gamble
here he takes a pawn and the white king
moves Classy Touch from Levon he's now
two pawns up he's going to win this end
game and King E8 was necessary from
leavon so he had this all worked out a
rook G6 check this is close because the
black pawn is also a passer but white
Queen's first with check David that was
instructive finish incredible finish
speed accuracy from leevon aronian in
the end game he lost control for a
moment but as soon as he regained that
control he wrapped it up nicely and uh
Vincent logs off let's go to the
division three final where we see we see
a check mating P Robert oh my goodness I
we I think you're were going to say what
I was going to say it's an endgame it's
similar but no it's Checkmate on the
spot this black king can go nowhere
David it looked like a hopeless position
regardless but that ends the game
without question wow
yeah such symmetry there two Rook games
and ultimately two wins for the player
with the white pieces um just incredible
play there and uh yeah brish pegged back
after taking the first game he falls to
defeat
Robert both of these matches have been
oh so close and we do have one player in
the lead it's lvan aronian up one half
against Vincent Ker in division 2 with
that spot in the top division $155,000
on the line it's leavon Ronan who is on
his last life but is trying to catch up
to kimer and in division three Alexis s
wins game two he ties the score one AP
piece and the players with the white
pieces they've been shining in that
third division and that's why it is tied
one- one
split and uh wow Lebon Ronan showing his
class his quality but Sana we talk about
it with the white pieces he's almost
unplayable truly world class with his
openings I wanted to point out his
endgame technique also Flawless here uh
with white he has an extra Pawn White's
E Pawn is uh spare here he has a three
on two advantage on the king side but
the technique with which he won this
game wrapped it up within a few moves
was just impressive first what to do how
to make progress activate the white king
it already looks great but there's a
clear path towards the black queenside
pawns he started walking in this
direction
the path was cut off temporarily with
Rook to C3 but now the white kingside
pawns can act as a distraction Pawn to
F5 a really nice touch calculating
correctly that after a trade of Pawns
Rook to G3 looks like it's winning one
of these pawns but no the door is shut a
check forcing the black king back to the
back Rank and now King to C6 a really
deceptive move after Rook takes Pawn
given a question mark but it was a lost
position anyway White's intention was
not to go porn hunting white simply
stepped forward King C7 and Checkmate is
inevitable next move and making that in
a rook end game a really rare uh sight
but uh it did bring SRA an important
win what an ending that was because so
many people say oh it's winning
regardless but in time scrambles if you
don't end the game on the spot that's
how you actually give away half points
or even full point so what awareness
from Alexis Sera he was up upon a start
at the end it was even by material but
check Checkmate that is the game Ender
so that was a nice comeback victory for
Sano beautiful mating net and talking of
the internet uh Opera and chess.com have
collaborated on the internet browser for
chess enthusiasts the world's first
chess browser has integrated chess right
into the sidebar so you're only ever one
click away from a quick game of blits or
a puzzle while you work you can even pin
the sidebar panel open so that you can
carry on reading watching or browsing
with one eye on the board while your
opponent plots their next move this is
available for Windows Mac and Android so
use exclamation point chess browser in
the chat now to download Opera for free
and take it for a test
ride and just like an opera the stars of
the show need an intermission we will
join them as will you and the audience
but don't go anywhere because when we
return it's games three and four of
these title matches in division 2 and
three of the Chess Masters 2023
Champions chess we'll be right
[Music]
back
I used to work at the bank from 7 to 6 I
was a stock market analyst I always had
an interest in this working under time
pressure and at that time I had a friend
it was Kristoff seli who was also
working at the bank during our lunch
times we often walked through the park
and and played chess as well I thought
one time well Kristoph you're you're so
good in explaining all this stuff why
don't you just record it you know make
make a video or something and maybe
other people can can listen to it as
well yeah and it all started from there
at the time I found YouTube which was
pretty new in 2011 and I uploaded my
first video on my chess explained
Channel and it was funny because I sent
Michel the video links so that he could
watch and give me feedback but all of a
sudden dozens of people
[Music]
watched later on when the channel was
larger I got plenty of people contacting
me about lessons and then I started
teaching yeah so the the channel was
really kind of the the beginning of
thinking about Chess as a career and I
quickly had a a full schedule like
basically teaching 30 hours a week
chess is such a beautiful and and kind
of multifaceted game and you find
something new every day in chess
openings in particular which is my my
forte I'm thrilled to find new ideas
present them to the audience and and
help them to play a better and
entertaining
chess totally fascinating if you talk
with Kristoff about Chess in general but
also specially openings he's like a
machine a Fountain of
Knowledge I I was always fascinated by
the opening phas of the game because I
think due to this fixed starting
position you have something very um it's
very explorable you have a very constant
thing that you can look
at yeah I think my my total highlight of
my career with with with chess and with
with chessel um that happened in 2020
when pretty much out of the blue I got
this offer to work together with Peter
hin and neelen Magnus Carson's Chief
trainer and second to write a course
about Magnus called the Magnus touch
about Magnus great ability in end games
in Middle games planning like all his
best games and ideas and I wrote that
together with Peter H it was a great
experience we were on yeah plenty of
Zoom calls that was in the height of the
pandemic it's pretty pretty
wild at the end Magnus recorded the
whole thing yeah based on my my script
which was
fascinating a real great experience to
get in touch with like the highest level
of chest which was completely
unimaginable before I never thought that
something like that could
happen it's just a a wild journey in a
way uploading a video in July 2011 and
from going there to the cooporation with
with Camp Magnus and then finally last
year in 2022 I won this author of the
year for chessel after having successful
courses in the past couple of
years it was just like impossible to
imagine when I just started doing like a
single video for my friend basically and
then at the end this whole thing
transpired it's just really
[Music]
unbelievable
a year ago Leana ronian did not
participate in all the events in the
Champions chest tour but he wants to get
out running in the 2024 Edition he leads
one na half over the pry Vincent kimer
David leavon ronian lost to Vincent in
the Winner's final now his back is
against the wall but his King is on the
wall and leavon was Pro that he is
indeed king of division 2 it feels like
Levon aronian woke up on the the right
side of bed today he chose violence he
got that win in a long Scrappy end game
there and uh yeah already a better start
for him than that match that previous
match you mentioned against Vincent it
feels like he's got this under control
he's brooming with confidence and nice
to see as I think as farro said a happy
confident Levon in form makes the whole
Chess World better so Vincent has a real
fight on his hands if he wants to win
division 2 and get that coveted place in
the top division next time Le is an
incredible player at his Peak he was the
number two rated player in the world
he's the fourth highest rated player in
history and you know he's been through a
lot in his personal life he's also ex
changed federations from Armenia to the
United States but he is a national hero
in his home country I mean seriously
everybody knows him he's a household
name and he led them to Olympiad glory
on several occasions so leavon uh he
isn't just an exceptional player he he's
an exceptional person and he also is a
hero in
Armenia really popular as a person as a
player and uh maybe one player who's not
enjoying levon's company right now is
Vincent kimer who needs to win and wow
Robert PA
F4 play chess for a long time I've never
seen that one it makes sense he is just
trying to take control of the center and
prevent black from thinking about E5
does it actually stop E5 does it
transposed to some kind of four pawns
Kings Indian David I'm equally confused
here E5 does not look easy to play and
it's leavon who has less time out of the
opening for a
change wow yeah the opening the white
pieces actually we've seen in both
finals division 2 and three today it's
been essential starting strong with
white Landing the first surprise playing
on the front foot attacking if possible
and uh Vincent this isn't necessarily an
aggressive move it's just to control
it's very positionally strategically
sound and uh yeah leevon aronian he's
forced to go out on a limb literally the
black light now sitting on the rim um
just in order to chip away at the center
and okay I'm firstly impressed by
Vincent's opening idea I nearly never
see him kind of go this risky this early
but I'm also impressed that Levon
reacted so quickly to this surprise
maybe I need to do my research about
whether this is a known idea but uh
White's taking all the space Robert it's
just a clash of ideals here White's got
the space but uh Black's got some hidden
dynamism and some holes in the white
Camp to look at potentially later this
E3 Square that's one of those holes and
it can transform into a moroi bind
structure where if white pushes a pawn
to E4 we have one Pawn on C4 one Pawn on
e4 stopping Black from pushing pawns
forward so that's one of the major ideas
in these types of positions I don't know
how quickly Vincent will want to shut
down his own Bishop on the light squares
which looks like a phenomenal piece
but leavon he hasn't moved yet so David
the hes in the position that you're
talking about E3 I was about to say is
Knight G4 possible he answers yes answer
is yes and this is Kitt look at the two
black knights they're jumping they're
hopping around setting uh kind of
threats here and there but as long as
they can be fended off Vincent will feel
comfortable so Levon has to continue
being energetic um investing time now he
has to figure out what to do next how to
justify these night if the Black Knights
are forced to retreat sadly then um yeah
I think White's just going to be
enjoying this position enjoying the
extra squares the space that he has um
so I'm looking at forcing moves here
Robert C takes D4 kind of Screams to be
played trading off a pawn in the center
trying to lengthen the diagonal for his
own Bishop but uh the follow-up unless
it's Pawn to E5 I don't really see it
and level retreating this is a bit of a
worrying sign to me given a question
mark by the computer
and uh in my opinion at least
understandably so it feels like you've
wasted so much time now this is
literally the uh third time the Knight
has moved and back to a square sat on
just a few moves earlier um surely
Vincent now is able to consolidate and
enjoy the space he sto why not still
more space pushing the pawn to D5 that
looks Pleasant to my eyes there is a
threat directly on this Pawn on D4 all
of Black's pieces staring there and as
you said David this night it went to C
first out to A5 back to C6 the Knight on
G4 it went up to F6 and out to G4 and
how was white dealt with that when the
Knight came out to G4 white simply slid
the queen up when the Knight went to A5
White created a Connect Four a pawn
chain so the dynamism that black is
playing for David I'm not sold on it
just yet because Knight takes F3 e takes
F3 as a response doubling your own pawns
that looks attractive to me to gain
control over open files you can also of
course take back with the bishop so
David I'm not feeling the loss of time
from Lon ronin's
perspective I think he's uh playing for
tricks here understandably but yeah one
track mind on tricks often you forget
these strategic factors you forget about
kind of the bigger picture Tempo in
chess is so important I just want to
point out one trick don't play Pawn to
E3 here trying to kick out this black
knight from the center Pawn to E3 would
backfire badly after Knight takes E3 and
uh suddenly the trickery of the Black
Knights comes to the fork Queen takes
Knight allows a family Fork a royal Fork
here hitting the king queen rook in the
corner and black so Vincent of course
he'll spot this he'll uh avoid this pitf
but um yeah why not Castle the white
king as you said it's not a threat from
black to trade off Knights if uh White
allows it on his own
terms I feel that uh Vincent he's still
got a bunch of time on the clock he's
reacted so well to levon's plans and
tricks here
and um yeah I'm just loving the white
Pawn chain you know me Robert my
favorite game Connect Four white has got
that on the queen side you're
highlighting it before I even finished
and yeah this a beautiful position for
Vincent we've done enough coverage
together for me to know exactly uh where
you're heading and this Pawn chain is
heading towards the black king side you
would like to continue pushing pawns up
the board at some moment to gain some
additional space and he has in fact
castled the bishop goes to D7 so David I
think in this one of the status quo it's
being maintained at the moment and uh
White seems to be more harmonious and
that's why I would prefer Vincent's
position look at these these Night Moves
one night went to the rim the second
night on the rim I just feel like white
has done a series of natural choices and
black is trying to find activity
wherever he can trying but so far
failing leevon aronian and now two
obvious moves come to mind either p E4
or Pawn to G4 keep pushing uh be
consistent look at that beautiful Pawn
chain that white has established all
over the board gaining space in the
center holding everything together still
a long long time before we see black
finding counter players so a great start
for Vincent in his quest to strike back
and equalize this match at least um
maybe we zoom out temporarily Robert um
I think that question mark by the way a
bit harsh looked like a very nice move
for white but let's check out what's
happening in the division three final
let's check it out because Alexis s
Alexander Guk they're kned up at one
game a piece so as Vincent kimer
continues to claim space on the left
hand side of our screens look at the
right hand side of our screens alexe has
the black pieces we've talked about how
he
struggled when he doesn't have first
move advantage and Alexander Guk he has
six minutes to his opponent's 9 plus
this on the right hand side of our
screen David not at all sh Shing that g
is down on time yeah uh we'll repeat
that a lot today Robert and uh it is a
really important factor of course
especially in Rapid chess gish's clock
handling uh for himself it's stressful
for his opponents it's uh kind of it
just has this temptation to play on time
um it's one of the most important
factors in the position but I've got to
say I like White's uh chances on that
board we talk about porn chains white is
the one with the porn break white can
chip away at the black center and uh
White has kind of more centralized pawns
here I'm looking at White switching the
attention over to the queen side there
we go grishuk on the right board pushes
a PA forward to C4 like dynamite and the
black king also a bit Airy so um I think
a good start to the game by gisher of
course it's still roughly in the balance
but yeah as long as he can keep playing
relatively quickly I like his chances
how about
you I've listened to you I like his
chances as well but I have to be honest
my eyes are are back on the kimer
aronian position because leavon aronian
he took game two in a Time scramble if
we dive right back into the position
between kimer and aonian look at this I
mean what has black done in the last few
turns I think his moves where Knight
back to H6 Pawn to A6 King to h8 like
he's doing a whole lot of nothing and
after this latest move B5 look at how
high the evaluation bar is David it's
through the roof and why explain to me
why just steal a pawn in the
center I'm struggling to see a reason
not to get greedy here um why not grab
material while you can I mean look at
the space we talk about space as kind of
uh just a general factor it's about
which squares you control here it's uh
it's very kind of aesthetically obvious
what white has done white just has
infiltrated the enemy camp uh normally
your battle lines it's your four kind of
uh ranks are your territory the
opponents for are theirs and white has
stepped across those boundaries that
Black Knight on H6 is terrible and look
at this classy move from Vincent he
wants to take that pawn with his bishop
and uh black cannot take twice on the E5
Square because look at that Black Knight
on H6 it's hanging in a lot of
variations the White Queen has its eyes
over in that
direction going to say it he's crushing
Levon in this game and it's rare to see
uh such a one-sided position Robert um
like something that
Vincent might get in a simultaneous
display I've got to say this is rare to
see leavon aronian playing with no space
he's the dynamic player he loves playing
adventurous chess but whatever Adventure
this one was he never wants to repeat it
because he has no space white is just
continuing to launch an assault against
the black king side D4 is dropping so
white may just go up a pawn D6 is now
under attack twice thanks to Knight on
e4 and as you said David taking on E5 it
makes matters worse because you can't
take a second time with the Knight on H6
being loose and you don't want to open
up the f file for the white Rook so I
don't even see how black continues here
maybe some simple moves like Rook to C8
but that's a one move threat that white
can simply defend even by bringing a
rook to C1 this looks miserable I can't
come up with much of anything for black
besides one move here one move there
David do you see any hope at all for
leavon
h i mean I want to see hope Robert I
really want this to be a proper fight
but I don't uh I just think that black
is busted at this early stage um I've
got to say I'm impressed that Levon
still got his Poker Face inside he must
be bubbling just thinking all that hard
work to get that win with white in the
previous game U kind of that beautiful
end game technique and it's all been
well run away in a difficult opening
here he was hopping around with the
knights and that's why I guess for the
newer players with us we say don't move
the same piece twice in the opening
until the rest of your army is developed
at least um I mean he moved his
queenside Knight what was it four five
times only to see it get traded off the
kingside Knight has hopped around the
board as well gone on a journey just to
sit passively uh on the edge of the
board
here I mean we can philosophize all we
want but ultimately black is struggling
Black's going to be a pawn down and and
just barely possible to find a move look
at this back on his starting Square
Robert this has been a real really
unfortunate game for leavon who is an
exceptional player I think he might be
aiming for some kind of F Pawn push to
gain a little bit of breathing room but
as soon as you touch your F Pawn that
gives the white pawn another Square to
jump to and this Knight can go into G5
anyway I just don't see any hope and for
those of you at home who are looking at
this say why is it so clear it's just
one extra Pawn it's that even in this
position white probably could almost
give up a piece and still have the
advantage because the complete control
of the board I do like Leon's move David
I think F5 was a good choice I am
responding with E6 I think it's
important to keep pressing forward go
after the black king in the corner and
expose this dark Square
diagonal Vincent now can start
calculating he still has 5 minutes he
knows he has a winning position but like
you said this is why Lebon is such a
classy player he's so energetic even in
Desperate situations like this we've all
been there we've all had opening
disasters uh I've had uh my fair share I
must admit but he's fighting back now F5
it was necessary and he's going to go
down fighting no matter what so um ear
killing off these top players putting
the ball in the back of the net
finishing the game is not going to be
easy um I like your E6 Robert if white
wants to consolidate then he I was going
to say might Retreat his Knight to F2
just to kind of keep the beautiful white
Pawn structure intact but he's closing
in for the kill the bar drops slightly
but still looks phenomenal I think your
E6 idea uh is up his slea it's coming
next it's Unstoppable there's nothing
that black can do you can put your own
Pawn on E6 and white simply takes it so
now H6 played it's time opening up the H
file may further hurt the black king H
takes G5 I'm wondering if I even have to
take your Bishop that's hanging on D7
this is how cramped how poor Black's
position is I mean David this is a type
of game we don't see from leavon very
often but I think we have to give the
credit to Vincent he was able to
capitalize where so many have not over
the
years and uh I'm already tracing it back
to the opening and uh this isn't Levon
necessarily getting outplayed it's just
him not surviving the opening stage and
that F4 move early on if that isn't
already known then that's going to
become trendy that's how much Vincent
wants to win this game how much respect
he has for Leon Ronan he's showing off
kind of rare opening ideas uh he's not
saving it for more important tournaments
this is the game he wants to win and uh
just below the boards there we see
Vincent 94% accuracy even in what has
been a really complicated battle Levon
it's not shabby 85% But ultimately um
it's just one or two mistakes kind of
gave him an uphill struggle from the off
and now Vincent's debating whether to
regain the PCS just sacrificed by taking
on D7 or whether to just keep the attack
going to go for the black king um still
some work to be done but uh an abundance
of choice and they all look winning
Robert it looks like he's dragging the
black king out into the open now uh
before he moves in for the kill and look
at this he doesn't even take the bishop
so white now is down a knight for two
pawns but I said it in the previous game
and I'll say it again a pawn three
squares away from a knight dominates
that Knight that Knight cannot get out
Rook F4 Pawn takes F5 Rook coming to H4
this king is also getting checkm so you
save some extra material for black as
yaser San likes to say if you're you
know going to uh what what is it if
you're going to die you at least you do
so on a full stomach and this is exactly
what's Happening
Here I love that saying I've got to
admit the porn grab's motto but
ultimately yeah it was just
visualization the white Rook anywhere on
the H file if it lands will be Checkmate
and I think that's how this game is
going to end Leon we see him on the
camera there just
uh he looks despondent he looks like he
knows the inevitable the ax is about to
fall on that black king and um this one
is pretty much decided Vincent powerful
play just uh I think he becomes the
favorite yet again for this division 2
final to book his place in the top
division next time just the manner of
this defeat Robert psychologically it's
going to be hard for Levon to recover
and for Vincent I he sort of is playing
with house money in a way because if he
loses even this game and leavon takes
the match well there's a second match
that will be played with two games
rather than four but that's you know
there a comfort zone for Vincent and
well this there's no comfort zone for
the black king here because there are
all sorts of checkmating Nets but maybe
the black king will slide out to G6
David that's Leon's last hope that there
isn't immediately a check mate it's not
like there's a mate in three by fource
and so he is going to try to bring his
King out and survive David we've seen
crazier things happen we have uh crazier
things have happened multiple times on
the Champions chest saw uh this rapid
format lays claim to these crazy things
and we're surprised by that one Robert
just so calm so cool from Vincent just
slides his King into the corner is that
sadism or is that uh is that just
genius I think it's a smart decision I
mean the engine the evaluation didn't
change at all and he didn't want to
allow a queen trade on the diagonal or a
check but David I would not have been
able to resist Rook H4 followed by Queen
h8 and just Sur founding the black
king I agree uh why hesitate when it
looked like there was a very direct path
to attack to Checkmate um it's just good
practical play from the youngster the
Young Generation they so good at
realizing kind of when to invest their
energy calculating and when to take kind
of a breather and I guess Robert that
plan isn't running away anytime soon so
he's just doing it at will at his own
Leisure um as the feature chat says
right now this game must be fun for
Vincent Vincent's definitely enjoying
this moment uh it's probably the only
time he'll get such a one-sided
encounter in his lifetime against uh
Levon aronian so might as well enjoy and
Levon down to one minute it's a matter
of time not much to do unfortunately you
can't create a threat with black just
the black Queen's too far away as we
said earlier it's on the wrong side of
the board cut off the board is in half
and Black's piece is still asleep looks
like fish a random chess Robert the
black pieces in the back rank well Lavan
is getting ready for the freestyle goat
Challenge and if I'm not mistaken
Vincent is playing there as well so uh
yeah Fisher random and that doesn't
start just yet this is chess and this
black king is getting checkm I don't see
a way out for it some of the ideas are
quite simple giving a check maybe bring
this bishop into the attack if you need
an extra piece but the black king he has
no Defenders and leavon he's got no time
under 30 seconds maybe he won't even
play a next move will'll await his next
move but then we will uh kind of zoom
out and see how the other game is
developing um of course Alexander G's in
time pressure over there I think that
would be breaking news to anyone not a
surprise in the slightest in the
meantime Levon does throw out another
move he throws his knight uh to F6 where
it will likely just get chopped off the
board but at least his King now has a
safe Square to hide on on G7 he cuts
across the white Queen's diagonal stops
any uh entry from that White Queen
Vincent what do you think is the
smoothest the cleanest kill here you
always want to cut out the opponent's
counter plate if possible but that's why
I'm so impressed by this game it's not
just that F4 move in the opening it's
the fact that I would be taking a knight
on F6 and saying at minimum I'm up a
pawn and I'm probably going to check me
your king anyway but he is thinking so
for all of you out there who uh you know
are watching this do what Vincent is
doing if you have enough time you want
to calculate so you can finish the game
on the spot and the near future versus
extending it and giving your opponent
some chances so I mean seriously great
from Vincent kimer now it's a matter of
taking this Knight throwing a rook H4
check first I guess actually Rook H4
there's Knight H5 all of a sudden and
even though white is still objectively
winning you have more to
prove yeah actually that one uh slips my
radar and Knight to H5 yeah as soon as
you see that that might be a defensive
resource you just take the Knight back
and you're actually still up material
and you're attacking with white but of
course it's Vincent he doesn't want to
he now takes the Knight after giving up
his rook and Robert are we going to see
a Checkmate the white Rook is going to
deliver the killer blow and look at this
bishop E4 that's why the king went to H1
all those turns ago Rook G1 is Checkmate
on the next move and so black may be
forced to take but you're allowing the
White Queen to recapture with check and
the Queen and Rook will do some form of
Latter Checkmate wow Bishop e for the
killer blow beautiful beautiful play and
Leon Aron with one two seconds left
finds Queen to C5 trying to give up the
queen for a rook on G1 but Queen G4 o
look at this it's forced mate uh you can
do anything here you can give another
check you can take this bishop and
Checkmate is coming Levon throwing his
Queen away did he lose on time no
Vincent though wins the
game what a game so
beautiful what a game from Vincent was
one-sided as he gets and we still have
another game going in division 3 but
Vincent kimer he evened up the score and
Alexander grishuk he's about to score I
saw the evaluation bar go through the
roof and the black king in this game too
David what is going on in the third game
of the match the players of the black
pieces do not want to protect their
King again we talk about the Symmetry uh
these clashes in the division 2 and
three finals it's as if lightning is
striking twice three times it's all
about the white pieces simply Checkmate
again the black queen divorced from her
King this is a recurring pattern don't
put your queen that far away don't get
trigger happy and start grabbing pawns
when you're about to get checkmated his
house is collapsing here s there's
nothing to do we've jumped in at a
moment where he is likely just about to
get checkmated or resign the only reason
he'll play on Robert here is because of
the clock but 19 seconds for gusik that
is in eternity by his standards and
there's that two second increment so
they can rebuild build their clock as
they get down into serious time trouble
and queen takes F6 or Rook takes F6
doesn't matter too much in terms of the
evaluation it's going to lead to a
Checkmate so there isn't anything could
that black can do David you're right if
this queen could jump through the Knight
to E6 we'd be talking about a real game
black would have great chances to hold
on but that Queen it's offside probably
snagged on a pawn over here wasn't wise
when your King has no Defenders we saw s
suffering on the camera there didn't
look happy at all grimacing wondering
how to even keep this game alive maybe
he'll throw the Black Knight into E5
just to kind of trade off the White
Knight get the black queen back
ultimately he's just going to try a few
more tricks to try and cling on at least
make rishik work for his win but there's
nothing to do and another Grimace he
knows he's losing and now he's not even
up much on the clock this
oneish mentioned it earlier he's going
for the central strategy and black king
Retreats he closes is in for the kill
here how to finish 15
seconds see him nervously looking away
at the clock occasionally he's got to
move Queen to E6 really nice one there
Robert multiple threats surely the black
position now is just collapsing but look
at San he's holding everything together
Rook takes F7 check by Guk ends the game
there so SRA put up some stubborn
defense and grishuk he saw right through
it look and we have SRA on camera down
two games to one da this couldn't be any
more different than the Winner's final
when these two went at it this is a
really even fight right now gisik has
brought his aame he's won twice with
white he struck twice against s and yes
s is better himself with the white
pieces but at the moment the pressure is
on him he will need to win if he wants
to maintain his two lives in the final
and uh at the moment he needs to recover
he looks really down now on the camera
and uh understandably so after pretty
much getting checked ated in that last
game when the chips are down the best
players they always bring their
aame and Alexander Gish in division 3
not just a super grandm at chess he's
also a stellar poker player so uh the
chips they are in his hands and reesi
Guk build a 2-1 lead over SRA and in
division two it's tied one and a half
one and half and leav ronian he jumped
to a lead after a nice win in game two
he is probably not a happy man and we
see him on camera no Smiles there David
no Smiles for Leon o ronian that was a
tough game one to forget he'll try and
uh yeah put that out of his mind in this
next game he does get white again and
Robert a big Trend we've seen today the
players with the white pieces taking the
wins uh just starting so strongly from
the off it's the opposite of the Tata
steel Chess Masters in the classical
tournament we saw in vikin a where black
was winning every game out of the gates
and then finally white was able to catch
up here every decisive game has been
from the player with the white pieces
and in this matchup between leavon Ronin
and Vince kimer that's good news for
leavon he needs to win this match and
then win another and Vincent he can
eliminate leavon he can end the
tournament right here win $15,000 win a
spot in division one in the second leg
of the 2024 Champions chess T if he wins
this game from the black
side big game now for Vincent as long as
he avoid defeat will have a great chance
of knocking out leevon aronian winning
the tournament or winning the division
at least but uh still another Italian
game uh yeah I think this is uh kind of
a sign that I should get some pizza or
pasta for dinner tonight but uh this
Italian brought leevon some success
earlier today will that pattern be
repeated Vincent looked uncomfortable
earlier Robert in this opening are you
surprised to see him repeat and allow
leevon to get uh this type of uh this
type of middle game yet again
I'm guessing that Vincent looked at this
during the break to feel more confident
and speaking of breaks he does break in
the center with D5 and then that Knight
didn't go to G3 so because it was on the
F1 Square it goes over to H2 and David
you played the Italian growing up a
knight on G4 that really is going for
the score all right a knight on G4 it
recurs it's a known pattern in the
Italian game in the Spanish and it's
often
uh now it's been chopped off but it's uh
often in conjunction with an attack and
I'm wondering how white generates this
attack against the black king does the
white G Pawn step forward does white
play a move like Knight to H4 into that
uh F5 Square there we go the knife has
uh been let loose now it's about to land
but first Vincent plays Rook to d8
exclamation point there Robert this just
must be very very deep preparation um
aesthetically White's uh position looks
great but maybe Vincent's just worked it
all out it looks like a dream come true
from the white side but that move Rook a
d8 deserves an exclamation point you may
ask why aren't you just lining up your
queen and Rook against this loose Pawn
on D3 that absolutely is what you're
doing but you're also ignoring moves
like G5 this Pawn on H6 is a hook that
allows white to enter Black's position
and start going for the king a knight on
F5 looks scary but a knight can't
deliver checkmate by itself so Rook ad8
a composure from Vincent kimer and also
fantastic preparation now it's leavon
who needs to prove that he can gain the
upper hand against not just Vincent but
the Silicon friend that he studied this
position
with and uh psychologically that is
tough Levon aronian in his mind right
now of course he's trying to calculate
moves he's trying to figure out what is
best he's going to try and look three
four steps ahead if he can but in the
back of his mind as you say Robert it's
really disconcerting to know that your
opponent has studied this in depth maybe
Vincent spent the whole of last night
the whole of this morning just kind of
studying this opening figuring out how
to survive as black how to kind of even
pose problems for white and it's a
double-edged sword if you try to kind of
surprise Vincent back then you know
you're not playing the best move but if
you continue playing what you think is
the best move you might be walking
further down into that uh that kind of
Labyrinth that the computer has set out
and uh explained to Vincent so really
tough situation for me this is one of
the hardest things with modern chess
Robert um kind of the psychology
involved with opening
preparation amazing preparation from
Vincent he was shaky in that second game
which leavon eventually won here in game
four he says no problems for me instead
of sitting passively getting outplayed
when my opponent takes control of open
lines I am going to be the first one to
the open Line give me your D3 pawn and
it needs to retreat with moves like
Bishop C2 you're heading in the wrong
direction so I really like how Vincent
has changed his opening from a couple
games ago and leavon is down by going on
two and a half three minutes David we do
not see that often at all we really
don't and that's Testament to the
strength of Vincent's opening
preparation we saw him in the previous
game straight up from the bat you know
uh just winning with white pretty much
by move 15 now with black yes it's level
the computer the EV valuation bar we see
there says it's dead level but uh again
instant reply by Vincent the Bishops
Dart sare Bishops are off now white is
pretty much committed to attacking only
on the light squares and um yeah no more
Bishop pair to talk about but Levon for
the first time Robert he's going to be
breathing a s of relief H Vincent is
thinking Vincent clearly oh commentation
curse I was about to say clearly for the
first time on his own but nope the
Knight leaps into D5 attacking White's
rook and looks like a position in the
balance you are highlighting the White
Knight jumps in the near future first
the white Rook has to move or you have
to take this Knight but um yeah it looks
like this could go either way uh really
really delicately
poised taking the Knight on D5 it rids
black of his most active piece but also
rids you of the advantage of having a
bishop when your opponent does not have
the same so great preparation seriously
from Vince and kimer that felt like good
news for second for leavon because
Vincent paused but then he's like oh I
remember it's Knight D5 here and as you
said the psychology is challenging
because for leavon if he makes a move
that causes Vincent to think is Vincent
thinking because he is as deep as he's
gone in his studies or is it because
leavon didn't make one of the top three
moves that the elite players often study
so this is I think an uncomfortable
position for leavon taking on D5 seems
to eliminate many of the winning chances
that you can get by having a bishop
against your opponent's Knight but
leaving this Knight here not just to
attack The Rook but to jump into a
square like F4 and pile up pressure on
the D3 Pawn that doesn't look very fun
either so David Advantage Vinted kimer
for
sure I mean he's going to be loving the
outcome of this opening look at the
clock four whole minutes up uh this is
already move 19 move 20 and Vincent's
barely paused for thought so huge huge
psychological advantage coming off that
last win as as well H yeah Vincent he's
riding a high and I fear for Lebon he
moves his Rook at the very minimum the
Black Knight can Retreat to F6 no he
puts a porn on G6 rendering that White
Knight on the rim very very dim and um
yeah I love it from black he's going to
put the black king on G7 in the near
future and not obvious at all what white
is going to be doing and uh Robert as we
leave Levon to figure out a plan for
white maybe we zoom out and uh go to the
division three
final let's do just that because if my
eyes if they're telling me the truth it
looks like Alexander grishuk with the
black pieces already has a winning
position and as we look at the right
hand side of our screens that is why
look at the last move played from Guk I
think he just wins a
piece wow what's happened here we were
just singing s's praisers world class
player with white just un breakable
opening repertoire is it just the Heat
of the Moment is it needing to risk
everything
you're right just White's position
collapsing Black's King is just going to
dodge this check White's just
temporarily a por up but his Center
which looks so proud so beautiful is
falling apart um we foresee this
becoming Messy as s still got chances
he's three minutes up at least I'm
looking for some consolation for him
maybe we just point out Bishop to or
Bishop to D2 Bishop anywhere Queen takes
D4 is the winning idea you're losing a
piece by force check to the king check
to the Knight on E5 this Knight can give
a check on F7 but black is able to take
it this is exactly what we're going down
and gets at minimum two pieces for a
rook and two pawns now a rook and two
pawns is worth seven um the Knight and
Bishop combination here is it worth six
or seven that's a debate that I'm not
going to get into but what's not up for
debate is that this white king is In
Harm's Way and C5 is a great move from
Guk he is not just resting on his safer
king and the minor pieces he's going
straight for this enemy King and if this
Pawn pushes to D5 you have a healthy
connected pass Pawn but your Bishop is
now disconnected from the queen and
moves like Queen F6 into D4 not to
mention the bishop is loose so David I I
think this is just
over I agree and uh it's bad news for
SRA but good news for us Robert good
news for everyone at home because if
grishuk uh wins this game then we get
treated to more chess and uh we love the
uh we love the battles of course more
chess is only better for us um but yeah
C5 what a classy move I normally would
disapprove because uh conect4 White has
won that but it's all about the dark
squares and the white king don't lead
from the front in the early middle game
like this you will get hit I'm watching
out for moves like Pawn to C4 in the
near future the black Bishop will drop
back to a nice Dart Square diagonal some
juicy attacks against that white king
the white Bishop loose White's Rooks no
open files for them so clearly inferior
to Black's minor pieces
big favorite but uh yeah still some work
to be done and S he's a bit of a tricky
customer he's so resourceful as I found
out many times playing on chess.com
against him I would seem to get good
positions and he somehow turns it around
in the one move later I just have to
resign but uh yeah it's big big
Advantage for black but work to
do and let's not forget that San doesn't
just need to survive this game he needs
to win which probably explains some of
his play in the game he's taking
tremendous risk because a draw is
equivalent to a loss for him so he's in
trouble I don't really see how he gets
any activity of his own whereas Black's
play seems straightforward he might have
to jettison a pawn will San just to open
up some files for The Rook but it's uh
quite little and it's getting quite late
as he goes down this variation I do
think the black queen can just take it
and Retreat back to where it came from
and the Black Knight now gets access
into the center there so David this is
great play from Guk it's been an
excellent match from him he's uh just
banging form today nice to see from
grishuk um he had a tough time against
SRA in their match earlier in the
division but today just looks like a A
Step Above um this is really him firing
on all cylinders Queen to E7 keep things
safe and like you said two more moose
black wins Knight C6 Knight D4 game over
as soon as that Knight reaches an
outpost no resistance at all possible
covering his back rank solving all the
issues and I agree with the feature chat
just there Gish about to strike again uh
Robert maybe it's time to zoom out and
check out developments in division
two there's very little debate in this
game even Alexis San is like okay you're
winning this game Sasha well done we're
going to get a reset but if gruk wins we
will have a second shorter match between
him and serona it'll be a best of two
rather than best of four and that will
determine who wins division 3 there's a
lot of prize money up for grabs in
division 3 they also get to skip the
play in which is a really tough
tournament we saw Fabiano Carana
struggle in the playin I think he only
three and a half out of eight didn't get
to the division placement stage so Guk
he's doing well let's dive back into our
board on the left hand side between
leavon aronian and Vincent kimer because
David when we left we liked what Vincent
was doing and now that we've returned if
Bishop D1 is your exclamation point move
it's because it's your only move as your
pieces are threatened in the center and
on the side of the board this looks very
weird and discombobulated From lon's
perspective yeah Bishop D1 exclamation
point yeah as you say that's probably uh
the type of exclamation point you don't
want it's so depressing when you have to
retreat your Bishop the proud beautiful
Bishop on B3 your Italian Bishop that
you developed so early to a nice ah
light Square Robert you're the artist
there I agree I approve of that emoji
but uh I also want to point out Vincent
can force a draw I believe in this
position if he wants uh with black
normally that will be a good result but
he's playing from a position of strength
here maybe um but Knight to D5 I just
wanted to highlight hits the white Rook
no matter where the white Rook goes I
think it needs to step forward to E4 uh
to avoid a knight jump into F4 the Black
Knight can Retreat back to F6 and we
could see an eternal dance between the
black rook and the white Rook uh sorry
the Black Knight and the white Rook and
a repetition of moves because white
would be tied down to the D3 Pawn
backward Pawn so Vincent he's Robert in
these positions I always find it tricky
it's like you know you have that safety
net you know you have the advantage but
to kind of find it within yourself to
press for more to push for more when
you've already uh kind of done such a
good job with black it's not easy uh
it's not uh kind of obvious either what
he's going to be doing next if not move
like Knight to D5
if the times were reversed Vinson just
makes that draw sends us to Armageddon
but with the lead on the clock and with
a healthy position it's not like white
is threatening anything the E5 Pawn it's
attacked twice but with more valuable
pieces than this low Knight on C6 so
black what other moves come to mind
besides Knight to D5 maybe Rook E8
though I don't fully see a plan if I'm
being honest I can see how the Rook is
better on E8 than on f8 but I don't know
if you gave me a free turn after that
what I would do so David do you see any
actual plans for the black
side it's hard like you say there's a
couple of obvious moves but um they're
not part of a bigger grand plan this is
the grand final but no grand plan for me
um rout E8 I quite like maybe bring that
Rook round Rook to e86 to D6 of treble
up um some type of uh alakin gun as they
call it when the three heavy pieces are
starring down at the pawn but then the
white Bishop defends that pawn and then
I'm not sure what next so um that type
of position I think Vincent's mulling
over the options the longer he thinks
Robert the more he might be tempted to
take it to Armageddon and take his
chances there now the clocks are
leveling out or what do you think he's
going to
do such a tough call I think Knight D5
back to F6 he's probably feeling good
about his chances in Armageddon but the
position is Pleasant for black it's not
like there's a ton of risk at the
current moment but the more time that he
spends on this turn the riskier it
becomes because Levant did outplay
Vincent in game two in mutual time
travel we've been talking about all of
the white wins today we've seen so many
of them maybe apart from this upcoming
gck game but uh yeah a draw with black
you can't fault Vincent if he decides to
bail out and what grishik would do is
repeat once and then do something else
we've learned that earlier the classical
wisdom of asserting your psychological
dominance teasing your opponent with the
prospect of a draw and then snatching it
away from them playing more moves but
Vincent I think this is a big giveaway a
big hint a clue as to his mindset he's
going to play Knight D5 now it's just
too risky to play on under three minutes
he's just Frozen right now and um yeah
the more he thinks the more Levon might
be tempted to gamble if Vincent
ultimately decides that he does want the
draw so don't leave it too late Vincent
decide on something play on or move the
Knight into the center will we see this
repetition unfold look at that 99.9%
accuracy
Robert that is just astronomical out of
this
world yeah he has played a perfect game
with fantastic preparation and we see
the repetition so he has repeated the
position and there's the third time a
draw is agreed upon by the rules of
Chess at the same position occurs three
times the game ends so that means that
we have Armageddon everybody's favorite
uh except perhaps the players David
because it's a nervy situation with it a
being a two- two tie in division two
final be a bit of a lottery will Levon
aronian be able to win that Armageddon
and keep the final alive or will Vincent
take it and wrap up division 2 uh
meanwhile this game still ongoing but
the evaluation still the same here
Robert uh I'm just doing a quick count
black has two powerful Bishops for one
white Rook same number of Pawns each
right now yes white can grab one on B7
there we go but uh ultimately I'm
favoring the pieces here every time Chri
is within his
grasp this is not even a question mark
you know for not question mark a
question for either player now the
Knight comes into D3 trying to win this
Pawn if you stop the knight from coming
into D3 you drop G2 with check so he
goes Rook to D7 but Pawn to C4 every
move for black is abundantly clear just
push your Pawn bring your knight in
steal the queen side there really is
nothing at all that SRA can do despite
having a four plus minute lead the clock
so David you know what that means we
will get a grand final reset between
these two I have no doubt that Guk takes
this game I mean a draw is still a match
win so heading into a a reset do you
think that it's Guk now who has the
advantage because he'll be feeling more
confident after taking down SRA in a
match defitely feels that way it feels
like grishik today his form has been
slightly sharper than sanas he's been
spotting tactics he's been seeing
checkmates he's been winning pieces
straight from the opening and in Rapid
chess opening preparation counts for a
lot it feels like gish's taking this
game this match really really seriously
and he's determined to win S I don't
know about you Robert it just feels like
he's not quite his quick kind of
confident self in this match it feels
like he has yet to find at least today
uh his feet King to G3 now Gish can
bring that Knight into D3 takes this
Knight he's delivering a check a fork
he's going to win all of White's
queenside
forms he only needs a draw in this one
Grand Final reset is guaranteed no
matter the outcome uh it's going to be a
lot of fun to watch uh we get more chess
from these two great warriors look at
the white king if it's going to die it
might as well die on a hill King on
H4 yeah coming in with the white Rooks
for the first time maybe grishik with
some nerves to deal
with 30 seconds only surely we won't see
a turnar around here we said it was
automatic it looks guaranteed Rook to G
I think the move to shut the
door and now I think you move the Knight
out the way and then push your a pawn
and Knight D5 is a fork A4 A3 A2 is the
very clear idea and the only threat that
white has is protected on the G7 Pawn so
SRA he's gonna try and if grishuk let's
say he had three seconds rather than
nearly 30 perhaps I'd be worried about
his position for a second or two but no
this is just a game especially because
of the in two seconds added to the
player time with every move they make
the only way David is if gish's internet
goes out that would be an absolute
tragedy seen that type of thing happen
before in the Champions chest tour wow
the players they repeated the position
once there me gisik such a perfectionist
of course he's not going to take a draw
even if it's enough he wants to win
Knight A2 Robert normally we say Knights
In The Rim not a good idea but here it
just guides the pawn it's The Shepherd
of the C Pawn it's Unstoppable now C3 C2
C1 Queen it's going to cost
white desperate counterplay on the other
flank is
totally just promote this Pawn there is
no Checkmate on the king side but Guk is
doing the smart thing and just verifying
he can even bring his King up to H7
because the queen could block on H6 but
this is good enough Alexander Guk wins
this game he wins the grand final match
three to one and that means we get a
reset because it's double elimination
and SRA he was unblemished to this point
but it takes a player like Alexander
grishuk to take a player like sran
down incredible play from grishuk
winning two games with white and
striking the first black Victory we've
seen in any of the finals today and uh
there we see the scores Robert 3-1 I
think an accurate an accurate
representation of the play in their
games this is definitely a match that
Alexander Guk deserved to win and in
division 2 two with a spot in the top
division in the next event on the line
$115,000 first place prize and those 50
tour points uh in division 2 leavon
Ronan Vincent kimer nothing separates
them they both won a game they drew the
others and that means we will head to
Armageddon but before we do David why
don't you break down a critical moment
from G Shook and sr's game and uh that
game was ultimately decided quite early
on by a big opening slip bit of a
blunder from Alex s and a rarity because
he's so strong with the white pieces
this was the early stages of the middle
game the white king is a Target on this
F line gish's last move was to play Pawn
to F5 trying to blow open that side of
the board but Saran if he'd kept his
call and just captured this Pawn then he
would have been relatively safe the
white king would be safe here because
black cannot take with a pawn to try and
play the idea that we soon see in the
game Pawn to F4 because suddenly there
would be a discovered attack the White
Knight Will leap out the way away for
example with a check and winning the
bishop next move but look at what
happened instead he allowed the pawn to
survive he jumped in with Knight to E5
instead yes attacking this Pawn after
Knight to C7 his final chance to
eliminate this Pawn instead he ignored
it Bishop to C4 a clumsy move allowing
Pawn to F4 allowing the pawn to drop
with check but as we pointed out this
white Bishop is doomed you cannot move
it because Queen takes what simply wins
the house wins a piece instead San was
for to try and muddy the waters But
ultimately he was always down on
material his King was always getting
attacked and he
never a masterclass from
alexand Fantastic technique from
Alexander Guk he played an opening that
was combative he didn't try to get
overly solid and it did help him secure
match Victory so we will get a reset in
division three between Alexander gup and
Alexis s but in division two we are
heading to Armageddon 2 to2 between
leavon Ronin and vit kimer who will come
on top we will see in just a few don't
go anywhere this is the chess BS in the
2024 champions
[Music]
chestor
all right first game we're going to play
is rapid fire all right I'm going to
name a sport and you're going to tell me
who the greatest player is basketball uh
Kobe Kobe all right baseball uh
shoot well the ones who play at the St
Louis cardal they have some players I
think what Mike mintini a player I like
him I meet him what about what about
soccer lonel Messi because he's very
consistent okay also since back in
college days he was already number one
and he's still okay he's recently number
one football my homies I watch him I
watch also his commercials okay tennis
yovic yovic all right I love it golf I
guess everyone says Tiger Woods but
there's this uh very pretty girl Paige
spir all right I like it all right what
about uh
poker I only know
Jennifer
Shah yeah I only know her and so you
hear that Jen Shah you're the goat
you're the go of Poker all right chess
chess uh Danny wrench okay come on
you're the best I appreciate it I'm
going to say Wesley so then you said
favorite right the favorite or who's the
goat who's the goat goat yeah hard to tr
i' say fisher for now but I I I suppose
the right answer is Carlson but I'll say
fisher because he's an American okay
just
boxing I'll pick my boy KY oh I love it
yeah he he hasn't done it yet but he I
think he might be one of the greatest
ever when he's done probably yeah he's
uh pretty pretty good your favorite
movie well say Lord of the Rings first
comes to mind okay classic I can watch
it uh over and over again but there I
know I like the the ver the newest bat
the Batman Okay three hours though the
this one so I like it yeah it's I think
best Batman movie ever okay favorite TV
show is the crown a TV show The Crown
yeah is yeah yeah I love it yeah we're
going to go watch it right after this
tournament the the the latest season I
love that's great that's great favorite
author I'd say sam Shanklin if he writes
more books okay well that's the first
thing that comes to mind like I I really
want to read leby roseman's book so I'll
get there one day well on L I'll ask you
who's your favorite chess Creator uh
well hikaro I I I love uh his uh twitch
streams although since his switch
websites I've been following him less
but when he was in twitch like I enjoyed
watching his uh title Tuesday stream
especially like yeah Blitz or classical
classical online or OTV over theboard E4
or D4 E4 fiser or
Kasparov H yeah hard question but I go
with Fisher at the moment closed or open
positions
open open positions Searching for Bobby
Fisher the movie or the Queen's Gambit
on
nlex yeah it's a tough question but I go
with the Queen's Gambit
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black in those coveted
draw ODS let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence
let the Armageddon commence those were
the words you heard the players they
first have to submit their bids to
determine who gets which color and well
the Armageddon could not commence right
away because these two players while
they had their bids Now set David the
first time around they bid the same
exact
number wow that is a statistical anomaly
so unlikely in the first bid they both
uh offered up 6 minutes 57 and uh
they're both clearly inside each other's
heads the second time around Robert
ultimately it was Lebon aronian who been
3 seconds lower and therefore gets the
black pieces and draw odds what do you
make of this who is going to be the
favorite uh with uh Lon taking
black I think that I like the extra time
for Vincent in this matchup leavon has
been super Speedy but he has slowed down
when Vincent catches him by surprise
like he did with an F4 move in their
previous game so David I'm thinking that
Vincent has the slight ND what about
you I think the trend of this game the
trend of the match sorry um it really
suits Vincent we've also highlighted the
fact that white has been winning a bunch
of games so far and that's with level
time that's with increment uh so
Armageddon having more than three extra
minutes up his sleeve Vincent should be
feeling confident it definitely comes
down to the opening though if he he can
launch another surprise catch Levon off
guard then uh he'll love his chances but
Levon switches it up it's now maybe
varying towards a Nimo idian no it's a
Queen's Gambit declined which variation
the regoin defense here and um okay
Levon he's avoided an early knockout
he's actually fighting for space in the
center this time Robert uh a much better
sign for him with the black pieces Qui
Speedy stuff so far and Vincent kimer
instead of maneuvering his Queen out to
A4 as typical on the ren he plays this
quieter approach by bringing his Bishop
to D2 to protect this Knight so this
looks like it could be a longer battle
and not a lot of tension between the two
sides th thus far and what was that
Queen C2 and then Queen to B3 David have
you seen this little stutter step before
no I must confess I have not seen this
it looks like you're just losing time
you're losing a full Tempo in the
opening especially every single sing Le
move counts time matters more than
anything and Vincent's moved the White
Queen twice that betrays opening
wisdom I guess he wants the bishop hair
he's trying to force that black Dart
Square Bishop to make a decision there
we go Levon doesn't react though and
yeah I've got to say Robert if white
gets an advantage here I need to rethink
everything I've learned about openings
then again he has the bishop pair he has
the isolated Queens borwn to look at um
he's taking big risks maybe this is just
genius he's so full of all these kind of
creative ideas Vincent really refreshing
to see and we know that Peter Leto is
Vincent Ker's coach his longtime coach
that has been a partnership that has
really worked out uh for Vincent's chess
and we see that white is behind in
development the king remains in the
center and black is saddled with this
isolated Queen pawn and deeper in end
games you don't want this Pawn on D5 to
be alone because you can't defend it and
a Pawn's best friend is another Pawn so
David I have to say I am biased in favor
of White's position here I love playing
against rather than with the
iqp and uh we're talking about
preferences here Robert you prefer white
I think I do slightly as well Levon
aronian stylistically he is not going to
be feeling comfortable he wants some
dynamism but where's that going to come
from I guess he's threatening Knight to
A4 now uh he's trying to put pressure
against that White Queen x-ray vision um
but that has been stopped there's a big
trap if the Black Knight moves from C5
potentially Queen takes E4 could be uh
available there's some pins here yeah
this is really interesting as I was
mentioning Levon not his type of
position I think that's what Vincent's
hoping for especially in a long game
he's got a four minute time Advantage
now Robert um speed wise it's looking
good for white this is up Vincent's
allei he loves these types of grindy
small long-term Advantage type of
positions and you asked me who I thought
the favorite was and it's exactly for
this reason that I picked Vincent the
clock situation is so unfavorable for
the player with the black pieces
normally in Armageddon because you bid
uh a lower time and the opponent starts
at 10 minutes but leavon this type of
position is uncomfortable you make one
strategic error you drop a pawn in the
center so he plays H6 a perfectly good
and legitimate move this bishop can save
itself David you could play Bishop to E1
you can play Bishop D4 Bishop E5 just
you can get it out of Harm's Way if
you'd like or alternatively you can just
continue with more natural moves like
Rook to see1 getting your Rooks to the
open lines I just feel like White's
follow-ups will be quite natural but
Vincent he on the other hand is taking
his time and while he's just making sure
it's King has led instructive this last
move for both sides newer players might
be wondering why did they just kind of
play irrelevant moves point to H6 point
to H3 it's so there are no back rank
Checkmate tricks uh long term watch out
for that to become a factor later uh so
just useful moves if you don't find
anything better why not just uh kind of
plan ahead for the future um really kind
of typical Blitz trick there for the
experienced speed chess players they
just want to avoid any tricks with their
King later in the meantime the queen
side has been closed locked down Robert
but uh still levon's moves aren't
obvious aren't instinctive and he's just
playing too slowly right now at least
this last move has active plans in mind
you can't get away with the Rook lift
all the way over to G6 just yet because
of Knight Forks but I love moves like
this you just start asking some
questions that your opponent may be
concerned about the Rook G6 at the right
moment not F6 over the G6 will be a
threat but for now it is under White's
control and on the other hand white can
play a move like Bishop to B4 try to ask
questions of this Knight here I just
want to quickly show that variation
David that you were mentioning earlier
that this Knight on C5 it cannot move
legally it can but you will lose the
game because if you ever move this
Knight let's say you want to attack the
White Queen it's the black queen that's
really in trouble because Queen takes
Knight on e4 it exposes a pin on the
defile where black may even get the a
piece back but at the very least white
takes back and is a pawn ahead so David
that idea you mentioned a while back
it's actually playing a huge role in
this game even if neither side will
actually blunder this tactic and it's uh
pretty much on the board Bishop to B4
the Black Knight feeling uncomfortable
but Levon he's threatening here
sacrifices Robert you could imagine the
black Rook taking the White Knight
blowing open the white King The Black
Queen will swoop in and maybe on a good
day there might be a Perpetual check uh
some kind of drawing Motif remember a
draw good enough for Levon so finally
he's been upping the speed in the last
few moves he's played the last few uh
turns within just a few seconds and
setting kind of these annoying threats
even if it doesn't work now it will
always be on Vincent's mind and suddenly
we see the body language Vincent the
hands aren't on the mouse they're on his
head he wers what to do next I would
play a move like Queen to E2 just to
guard against those threats forever but
uh Vincent he wants to play more
ambitiously there's calculation to be
done here those ideas of the pin that
you pointed out you could take this
Knight on C5 and go for that variation
maybe a lesser version for white however
ultimately Vincent has to maintain his
time Advantage it's started at over
three minutes it's now down to only two
and a half and the clock is ticking
still so tense here Robert surely the
clock will play a factor it's just feels
like neither player has really got into
that Armageddon mindset yet it started
in Vincent's style now it's in Levant
style there's a rook that just slid from
one side of the board to the other there
are exchange sacrifices in the air and
it's the king safety that is of the
utmost importance so a White's King
feeling in some danger a Black's King
tucked at home so the pawn structure
good for white king safety good for
black that's the trade-off that's the
dynamic equality that we see here so
David I mean I am starting to get
concerned for Vincent kimer as he
continues to burn clock here accurate
game from the two thus far but I feel
like it's easier to go wrong in the next
couple turns for white rather than black
98.2% accuracy we see on our screens
below the board not too shabby I mean
it's nothing compared to the 99.9 we saw
from Vincent in the previous game but um
yeah that is for sure going to change
the accuracy levels will drop as the
clocks H down zero increment but Levon I
just saw his eyes there robt on the
camera Dart up to the left side of his
screen I think he looked at the clock
he's like he's wondering here why
Vincent is freezing Vincent's been in
the tank for what two three minutes that
is too long you can't afford that in
Armageddon chess Rook to C1 and the B
slightly drops before Rec correcting
itself a fine move but it's a
provocative one he's asking leevon
aronia to sacrifice and Levon presses
the chaos Button he's all in and look at
that followup leavon had this worked out
out he is giving up another Knight so
he's down a rook for a knight and then
he's giving up a knight he'll be down a
rook but it's the black queen that heads
into H3 with a knight going into F3 that
would just be Checkmate so I'm going to
quickly show on the board maybe we can
bring up an analis board that Bishop
takes Knight on C5 would lose the game
on the spot because it's all about King
safety in these positions the queen
comes in and once the Knight takes on F3
the white King has nowhere to go the
best that you can do is give up your
queen for this Knight because the King
has no legal sares and that is just too
much extra material a queen for rook and
Bishop plus black has extra pawns plus
black has the attack no no no so in the
game David we have seen uh some moves
trickle in oh and Knight F3 going in the
wrong direction apparently but this
looks to my eyes like black is not worse
the white king out in the open and a
draw is actually a win for black wow and
he's walked into the the firing line
here Vincent he's trying to avoid a draw
by Perpetual check but he gives up the
White Queen the queen was hit anyway
there's a pin remember on the dline and
wow Robert the tactics Knight check not
taking the bait not taking the White
Queen he might do next move after the
white king moves because suddenly the
tension with the Rooks it's going to be
level material all the fireworks and
then an end game wow he's a head on time
as well Leon aronian what do you make of
this what tactical vision from him he
also needed to include Knight F5 check
first because had he captured on e4
right away his Knight would have been in
the king's sight so everything has been
perfect from leavon in this game you see
the accuracy at 97% that one move Knight
F3 check it received a question mark but
he's playing for the match a draw is a
win so we kind of can throw that
question mark out the window and now we
have liquidation but David we know how
this is in the end game the engin say
zeros is just a draw but my eyes they
tell a different story there are
definitely chances still
here for both sides Black's Knight could
actually jump to H4 threatening
Checkmate in two moves if the Knight
gets into H4 into F3 the white black
Rook will slide over to G1 the white
king is trapped in a mating net the
question is whether you rush whether you
uh jump into H4 first maybe white will
push a pawn to F5 and run with the white
king out to the open so you could just
maintain the Knight on this Square as
Levon aronian does but now there's
checkmating threats against the black
king Robert and the white Bishop will
drop back C3 m one threatened Rook h8
into the corner the black king breaks
out of prison and I've got to say three
results possible for sure but it feels
like Levon he's in the flow now he's
found his rhythm he's really woken up in
this game and it looks easier for black
to play Black has this constant idea of
bringing the Knight into F3 how is
Vincent ever going to stop it that's a
check meting threat that's the big
problem Leon's pawns are actually worse
A4 sticks out E4 sticks out the white
Rook can go after all of them B8 A8 E8
he's giving a couple checks if the King
goes to H7 you know what he wants to do
Rook takes G5 whether you get away with
that is a big question but King H5
protecting the pawn you're protected for
one turn but after Bishop F6 you're not
protecting it for a second so look at
this King H7 King H5 wrong putting your
King on the same color complex as your
opponent's Bishop not easy to do David
but leavon of course does it
not easy but the top players they're so
good process of elimination there he
calculated all of them really quickly he
realized this is actually the safer
Square deceptive but hiding in plain
sight and now the white Rook does go for
that loose eorn really important touch
there from Vincent kimer and uh okay he
gives up his F Pawn in the process pawns
are disappearing here Robert but rook
and Bishop T to work quite well as a Duo
it's just about whether the white king
is safe enough whether it survives
Leon's going porn hunting
leavon can get both of these pawns
perhaps but white is trying to go after
the queen side Bishops do well when
their pawns on both sides of the board
Knights they're slower moving pieces but
leavon is first to the punch and Rook
takes E3 then I guess vinance taking
over there on A4 but I think that black
you don't even necess want the pawns you
start throwing your own pawns up the
board you want to use your passers David
the last couple moves I feel like
there's some nerves at Play definitely
some nerves the players pausing for 5
six seconds on every turn even with the
more obvious decisions you can tell that
it's kicking in here um Levon knows he's
getting close pawns are disappearing
he's so close to safety he can even kick
the wiking back to its first rank now
and uh start maneuvering the Black
Knight the black pawns coming forward
but uh yeah meanwhile look at this he's
spending too long Robert he spent 20 30
seconds on this move Vincent also
feeling the nerves he was just trying to
survive trying to stay in this
Armageddon but uh he knows he'll get
chances due to the clock situation
that's pretty much guaranteed at this
point King back and Levon still needs to
be accurate and this is such a big move
because you're walking into a pin but is
this Pawn on F7 it's going to be the
heroic piece F5 F4 F3 F2 F1 I'm not
stopping there I'm just going to go down
the board and make a new Queen and
actually looks borderline Unstoppable
this is a position where black has the
most obvious plan and I can come up with
a second plan if you want bringing my
king up the board I can come up with a
third giving you a check and bringing my
Rook back to F2 try check you on F1 and
Vincent he pins the Knight it's not
going to be enough because the F5 Pawn
quickly runs forward David I think
leavon he has this one under control for
the moment yeah this this setup with the
black Rook uh on this Square the Black
Knight on this Square they're just
protecting each other um yeah it's just
genius there from Leon aronian checkm
one don't relax don't push your F Pawn
H6 is a mate but the black king can step
forward the most natural move in the
position hiding Behind Enemy Lines and
Vincent shakes his head he knows we're
going to get more chess today it's
actually a mate in two threat now the
black porn will step forward defend its
Knight a draw is enough for black but
he's winning here Robert Levon has put
on a master class these last few moves
it's been an amazing game from leavon
the way he handled first the isolated
Pawn then going for the attack and
playing it perfectly so here a rook
trade is on offer black king is too
active Black's pawns are more advanced
it's about the pawn quality not the
quantity at this stage with King G3 it's
about the checkmating net that we're
seeing here F3 F2 Rook e one is the big
idea and at any moment it feels that
black can do just this try to repeat
moves and make a draw or go after the
queenside pawns black is not in any
danger of losing David we are gonna have
a reset guaranteed a reset in uh pretty
much both divisions now uh Levon just
putting the finishing touches here the
fbn marches and white is going to be
forced to bail out with a draw if he's
allowed the opportunity Levon wants to
win though uh really nice to see and
Levon if he had five seconds left this
might be close but 55 seconds that is
way more than enough and uh the black
king is just going to March out the way
first a couple of checks and watch this
end game technique everyone at home rook
and pawn endings even without Black's
bwn he would be winning here but Levon
he's got it in the bag gifting us more
chess
leonan let me ask you David a draw wins
the match for leavon because it's the
Armageddon game but psychologically
speaking do you just win the game to you
know get that upper hand what he's doing
he could have bailed out with the draw
earlier now he's going to block with his
Rook this check and the black porn is
going to promote yeah that's a boss move
he wins it Levon aronian as you say
strikes a huge psychological blow and
stays in this division 2
final Lavon aronian needed to draw with
the black pieces he did more than that
he won the game he takes this Grand
Final 3 to2 but let's not forget Vincent
kimer he won their first head-to-head
match in the winners final it's double
elimination that was Vincent's first
match loss as it was for Alexis s in
division 3 so David we are getting extra
time we're getting the reset and that
means we're at an even point for the
players they're starting from scratch
now it's just a Sprint to the Finish
they just have to forget everything
that's gone on the scoreboards are reset
the level yet again I just want to point
out Robert the two players with
experience leevon aronian and uh
Alexander grishuk I'm going to call them
the grizzled Harden Veterans of of World
Chess they just used every bit of their
uh cunning to win those matches and I
was saying beforehand youth the energy
the kind of the pattern the way they've
been playing s and K so impressive up to
this point but now they've got a scrap
on their hands I think all bets are off
it's uh too hard to predict but the
chess quality level has been so high so
far today we've seen the accuracy
through the roof the energy the passion
very much the same I hope all of you
watching at home still have the energy
and the passion because there is more
chess ahead we are getting a grand final
reset in division three between s and
Alex Chris and in division two between
kimer and arone don't go anywhere the
chest World Masters 202 for Champions
chest
[Music]
t
take
[Music]
our once magnificent Kingdom of Chess
lays now in ruins our King slain but
some say that a new ruler will come and
restore the realm to its former glory
solve puzzles fight epic battles and
earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to to
reclaiming the throne download the app
today and this month only face off
against your favorite Kingdom character
Bots only on chess.com
[Music]
whether you're on a train or on a plane
or you go completely off grid with
chess's offline mode you can now study
chess anytime anywhere and not miss a
day of training and when you're back
online you just sink sychronized and
everything is updated
[Music]
automatically
a
[Music]
me
a
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
oh my God what an
armagon back in the ches Masters the
first leg of the 2024 Champions chest
store I'm Robert hes alongside me is
Grandmaster David Howell David we are in
the Grand Final and not just the final
but the reset because the players who
came from the losers bracket they won
their first match and that means means
we get another one free chess for all
extra chess overtime and in division
three we started with 32 players and we
are now down to just two and we're it's
a fresh it's a start one life left for
both of them it's a fight to the death
now in both divisions like you said
Robert it's a feast of Chess I think the
players are aware of us the fans they
want to give us value for money uh every
single move matters we're going to get
treated to the longest possible day uh
here in division 2 and three and uh this
is indeed the division 3 Bracket we're
left with two Sara we talked about how
great he is but he was taken down today
by grishuk revenge for the winners final
where Sana triumphed 3 to zero today we
saw a comeback 3-1 for grishuk and uh
yeah it's yet to be seen whether s is
able to regain his composure so much on
the line a lot of money on the line in
this next battle
oh yes and to skip the play-ins head to
the division placement in the next event
so there's a lot at stake including tour
leader points and so for those two there
is a lot going on and same in division
two between leavon aronian and Vincent
kimer heading into today's action
Vincent he had the leg up he came from
the winners bracket where he and knocked
down leavon aronian in the Winner's
final you see leavon beat Benjamin Bach
in Armageddon yesterday and now we're
getting a grand final reset in the Grand
Final we saw 3 to2 in aon's favor he
needed a draw and he won the Armageddon
David we get match number three between
these two Vincent kimer on screen here
is he selling the
underdog judging on that Armageddon
alone you would say yes leevon aronian
is brimming with confidence he's up for
the fight he's going to throw everything
at his young opponent but Vincent has
looked Supreme throughout this whole
week he's looked so calm progressing
through division 2 beating down uh such
world-class opposition I think it just
comes down to who can regain their
composure as I mentioned and who can
start faster it's now just two games
best of two maybe we'll see another
Armageddon Rober but uh it's about who
can just show their best in these next
few moves Levon can he maintain the
energy he's the older player he must
have exist Ed so much uh mental kind of
stress just fighting back uh in this
match and Clinging On to uh his life in
division two but in the meantime we see
a quieter D porn opening a queen porn
opening with h Vincent just getting the
pieces out this is what we call just
playing chess R it and I like this match
because we keep seeing different
openings and leavon rather than sitting
patiently and continuing with solid
developing moves he moves his Knight for
the second time in this game and so with
just one single night move from Vincent
he is offering a trade of pieces but
that was levon's idea is the bishop on
G7 opened up the bishop on B2 undefended
allowing him to play C5 and that pawn
cannot be captured so David in your
experience do you like this position
from the white or the black
side I must say that I'm not a huge fan
of this from the white side it feels
like you're playing for the kind of uh
real minimum here look at Vincent
scratching his head on the camera um I
think he's been move order tricked as
well um Black's Knight sitting in the
center nice and pretty I think if black
can establish this setup with the long
diagonal being open for Black start
Square Bishop um then he's the one who
holds the key uh the keyma to the
position and uh yeah it feels like the
porn breaks in Black's favor I don't see
any reason for white to be able to state
claim to an advantage maybe it's not
about that Vincent wants just wants to
get out of the opening and play but
leevon prepared up a minute on the clock
already Robert maybe unbiased but I
think he's really riding a high Vincent
yeah this opening Choice doesn't feel
like he's uh yeah he's being as incisive
we want to see those porn pushers F4 all
that stuff from earlier today but not
this one not this game it's not an
inspired opening and to spend all this
time and just make a straightforward
developing move it just seems like white
has not achieved what he would have hope
for black developing naturally leavon he
is playing pretty much instantly with
every turn and yet this is just a
position and so I think both players
will have to prove that they have what
it takes because there is no more Theory
to rely on it's just about who can come
up with the Better plan so the Kings
have castled we have seen safety to me
it just looks like solid play from two
exceptional Grand
Masters I'm pretty sure I saw this uh
this position down in the London League
uh in the basement in the minor section
when I was uh 8 years old it just looks
like both players just want to escape
the opening this is kind of a real
refreshing turn of pace at least for me
nowadays modern chess is filled with all
these really forcing opening lines up to
move 20 30 it's just a memory test here
both players just freestyling it's all
about who understands the position the
pawn structure better and uh Robert I
like to see this it's uh yes it's a
quiet start it's not as dramatic as some
of the earli games between these two but
uh ultimately best player wins in this
type of
position yeah it's just neutral
territory and white the engine often
says is slightly better but black has
done nothing wrong so leavon he sits in
for a think he is trying to figure out
what to do with this light Square Bishop
that's his one potentially problem piece
he can no longer go to G4 that's why
white put the pawn here you can't easily
go to F5 without being captured and
doubling your own pawns if you go to E6
six you're staring into your own Pawn so
while Black's position the foundation is
solid you have to come up with some sort
of idea B6 to get your Bishop out this
way well that doesn't speak to me either
because even when it gets to a square
like B7 it's staring into its own pieces
so I think that's the issue and while
this move was played David and the
engine SED creeping up a little bit in
White's favor I'm guessing that C4 it's
now or in the near future white is just
going to try to explode the center
might have to seize this moment Seize
the Day Vincent kimer here because if
you don't play C4 now Black's pieces
will uh be more prepared for it in the
next few turns like you said Black's
Rook will come to d8 eventually black
will solve the problem of that uh light
Square bishop and what else are you
going to do with white simply you've
already traded at one set of minor
pieces so you're not cramped your
opponent's not cramped and there we go
he goes for it C4 and um yeah I want
that Dynamite Emoji because this is very
much a case of se4 unleashing chaos and
things are lifing up it felt like they
come before the storm we said it there
we go thanks Robert the artist and um
yeah as we graffiti the board I think
actually it's leevon now with big
problems to face suddenly D5 is a real
threat for white more Central pawns
after all we've already seen Vincent lay
claim to the center and just gain space
without a fight D5 is exactly what white
aims for in this position and black can
take on D4 again white takes back with
the pawn we have What's called the
hanging Pawn structure and hanging Pawn
structure can be bad if those pawns get
attacked but white is just going to
press forward in the center with D5 and
if these bishops get traded off the dark
Square Bishops the black king is going
to feel like it is in some serious
danger uh you don't want to trade your
fien ketto Bishop if you want to protect
your king So this move D5 it's actually
quite a substantial threat if you will
doesn't threaten to win material but it
threatens to go after the black king
side David I much prefer White's
position all of a sudden just a couple
turns maybe this queen C7 move was just
slightly inaccurate and that's all it
takes sometimes for these super Grand
Masters to get the upper hand exactly
and uh I think that was the philosophy
the kind of uh the thought process
behind Vincent's opening we weren't so
enthus Robert I got the impression from
you as well it's just o it's just a
position it's a bit of a stodgy uh kind
of choice here but sometimes you lull
your opponent into a false sense of
security if you just play developing
moves if you don't attack them from the
off if they relaxed like Levon did with
that queen move suddenly you change the
pace Pawn to C4 open up the center and I
agree with you suddenly White's pieces
look far more centralized far more ready
for this action to happen than Black's
pieces and um leevon you can tell the
clock usage again he's not entirely
happy Vincent
99.2 accuracy still early days but uh
impressive stuff and Lon I think he's
got the worst possible version as black
against these hanging pawns that are
likely to appear on the board um ninja
time the alarm bells ringing for him as
black it looks like this trend will
continue in their mini match of the
white player with the white pieces at
least outside of Armageddon holding the
upper hand maybe this is a good time
while leevon thinks um okay Knight to A5
Robert I was going to say let's zoom out
and check out developments in division
three sounds like a good idea to me why
don't we do just that because they're is
another grand final reset happening
between Alexander Guk and Alexi ser and
we see that board on the right hand side
of our screen there is a bishop for
white compared to a knight for black
Black's pawns are worse over there on
the queen side and Alexi he has
struggled mightily with the black pieces
his openings with white are ferocious
they're deeply prepared but from the
black side it feels he always gets this
like slight disadvantage and you know he
struggles against these top guys and if
we dive in to this position a little
more I have to say it looks Pleasant for
gruk on the board and his time
management that's not so bad either he
still has plenty left there so David how
bad really are these split pawns on the
queen side for black or do you feel like
Alexi he's got things under control oh
well weak pawns are only as weak uh
they're only weak at least if the
opponent can attack them and here he
does have a light Square Bishop git if
he can somehow maneuver that Bishop over
to a 4 or B3 to sit on a nice kind of
supported Square then the pawns might
become weak actually if I'm trying to
think which pieces he wants to exchange
even if the Queens come off if White's
able to centralize his King later that's
going to be torture in the end game for
San he's not going to enjoy that at all
um I think the one piece exchange that
white here should be trying to avoid is
the bishop for Knight if it's pure
queens and Rooks I think ultimately the
black C Pawn yes it's weak but the white
D Pawn might also be a Target um so
grishuk he's maneuvering now this is the
kind of stepbystep phase of the game
where yes black has weaknesses but in
order to attack it it's a long-term plan
in the meantime the Knight drops back
Robert there's always going to be breaks
on as well Pawn to D5 watch out for that
to hit black uncomfortably in the near
future yeah I think White's Advantage is
potentially significant but uh it's just
again turning into something bigger
that's a real hurdle and S I think his
strategy Robert has just been consistent
throughout just tried to hustle on time
try to play quicker and uh it's had
mixed results so
far he's going to try to curl up into a
ball you get hide in the Shell trying to
protect all of his weak squares and
pieces because there isn't a second wave
of attack often times just one weakness
that's not enough to go after and win a
game you need to create a second front
if this Pawn were on H6 I think we'd be
talking about a pretty substantial white
Advantage because the black king would
be in some danger but I already see that
this can't happen I would drop a pawn
the spot and playing G3 H4 that feels
very slow it might be perfectly fine for
white but Alexi will see that coming
it's fairly obvious when your opponent
plays in that manner so is black going
to play C5 is black going to play E5
these are also questions that need to be
answered I feel like Guk is going to
continue to go deep in the think tank
and that means that s's chances of
survival I think are quite decent
because you need time to punish your
opponent and grishuk is short of that
the moment
and we mentioned s struggling with black
wo a pin there do not take this bishop
the black Rook is undefended behind it
there's a pin on the C file I guess the
black queen will step forward to D6
highlighted by the blue arrow there the
only uh kind of attractive way to defend
your C Pawn that's attacked I was going
to say s yes he's on the back foot yes
he struggled with black but at least
this is the type of position he can
cling on it's going to be a long long
game the other games that he struggled
today he was pretty much just wiped out
from the opening or uh it was kind kind
of a tactical battle where gish's moves
were easy obvious perfectionism does
come back to haunt you in positions like
this so grishuk looking away there um I
like this last move Robert why not
change the pace create a threat force
your opponent to react and ultimately he
does with this move Queen to
D6 and it seems like a one move threat
to my eyes to move Pawn to E5 trying to
chase the queen away hands black some
critical squares so the queen goes to C3
lining them all up on the C file Bishop
takes D6 is kind of a threat because you
can back it up with Pawn to D5
afterwards so black may be strongly
advised to play Knight to B8 and if
that's the case black is sort of
starting the next game resetting the
pieces and white continues to be on the
offensive but Rook to d8 next David you
made this point a while ago that
honestly Black's pieces they're
coordinating quite nicely you take a
step back with your knight just to open
up a line for your rook and pieces may
get
traded sometimes needs must and Knight
to B8 unattractive really ugly move
there but um ultimately it saves the
pawn it opens up that defile um I think
you should play it quickly here s just
throw the move back to Gish here um yeah
it's that type of position it feels like
two results more likely either it's
going to be a white win or if black
defends very well it should be a draw so
a nice position to be in here Robert
with minimal risk attached for Gish but
of course we'll keep talking about his
time because it is relevant and uh we'll
see whether he's able to keep up that
momentum he's built today uh with these
several victories against s still no
draws today I must mention in this uh
this Clash uh this generational battle
um in the meantime May Knight B8 on the
board maybe we zoom out and go to the
other game um which is very very
different it feels like two totally
contrasting battles here very tense and
Vincent does have that space Advantage
we're talking about f for forward on
that left board on of our screens he's
just played the move F5 he's now going
for the black
king and Vincent is diving in and going
for an attack let's dive into the game
and analyze a bit because this looks
very unpleasant for leavon this it's
been almost unrecognizable from his side
the positions he's been getting with
black where he has no space white has a
free hand on the king side going for the
attack David look at the last move E4
protecting your Bishop you don't mind
taking with the pawn on F5 and then
bringing your Rook to an open Line This
is a backwards E7 Pawn you can of course
take back with your Rook if you wanted
to so black has no real plans and ah
even E5 here Bishop takes D7 and E5
something like that that's going to hurt
the black king does not have many
Defenders around it hurt a lot Robert uh
in the near future there we go E5
immediately from Vincent striking uh
while the opportunity is there again
it's space it's it's just pushing pawns
it's black sideline Knights leevon his
uh his best black game by far this uh in
this Grand Final was the Armageddon
because he was able to get out of the
opening in good shape but here again
struggling and okay question mark for
that one but white r recapturing a porn
I don't think we can criticize Leon's
trying to seek solace in an end game and
Vincent I feel should say no there we go
the queen Retreats if white gets one
more move Knight to E4 with white a gets
into the game then um yeah this one's
just going to be decided it's going to
be over black is too many weaknesses and
an offside stranded
Knight it feels like uh you know I'm
repeating myself but history is
repeating itself here Robert as Levon
struggling with the space and struggling
with his knights in this uh final and he
plays King h8 because he wants to
coordinate his Rooks and uh you know you
spilled the tea on the position and
hopefully whatever whatever just dropped
is okay there uh this is live show for
everybody but black is going after the
white king here and so that last move is
just trying to give black some active
choices of his own but David it's going
to be a one move threat that can be
parried with a move like Rook to F2 so
how you feeling you you all good over
there flustered um it's gone everywhere
but chess comes fast chess comes fast
okay the the Coe is calculation over
everything not chess over everything so
if you need to clean it go for it sorry
we're having this conversation but this
is not this is not
I'm good head back in the game I mean
this is the type of obstacle we have in
our tournaments right Robert often stuff
happens you've got two minutes on the
clock someone spills a drink or
someone's having a chat and NATA behind
you you have to focus and that's my
challenge this time but uh yeah as you
say White's position still dominant Rook
to F2 really nice move we talked about
the clock in grick game do you think it
could trip up Vincent here suddenly it
is it's not a oneway street at least
levon's trying to mix things up trying
to go for the white king
need a few moves though to get that
black knight back
in he might start on the knight's
Journey Knight B7 but I don't know where
it goes to next you have to move the
queen and then bring the Knight out to
D6 it takes a lot of time and white on
the other hand is have to bring this
Rook to F3 and maybe even eventually put
on the last rank to go after this black
king so you mentioned Guk I just want to
note that his end game against Alexis
Sera that is still Level if anything
changes we will keep youall updated but
this is where our attention should be
because there's a spot on in division
one in the second leg of the champion
Chester on the line there's $15,000 a
$5,000 difference between first and
second and well David you mentioned
Knight to E4 I think here that looks
quite natural because you attack the
queen you may spring free a pass pawn
and this Rook on A3 and may still slide
over at any moment so that's not even my
arrow that's the blue arrow telling us
that Knight E4 is by far the best move
and well the Knight can also hop to F6
next going to uh be shot like an arrow
into the black position there we go
Knight E4 I wanted to say really tricky
Pawn sacrifice there from Leon aronian
White could have just taken that pawn on
E6 last move and viewers at home might
be wondering why not it's a free
material a big pass porn but then the
Black Knight would have been let back
into the game so it's much more uh
important it's much more urgent to
accelerate the uh Power of your pieces
rather than be greedy and uh change the
momentum and there we see another blue
arrow Robert it's time to jump in offer
that Queen trade and now this time
you're winning material or at least a
pawn but in far better circumstances
also the queen trade rules out all
counterplay how difficult do you think
that is though this move Knight F6 well
with the Queens being traded in the C4
Pawn loose I do think it's more
difficult than the blue arrow would make
it appear and yet Vincent when moves are
difficult he still finds them the queen
trade apparently just great for white
and I think it's because this Pawn E6
can be captured with the white pawn and
that becomes a runaway train it's not
looking back and it's I think black has
to sacrifice a rook for maybe a knight
and pawn but not going to be good
enough that's actually a beautiful
variation if the black Rook moves now
then white just leaves the Knight and uh
okay there's a counter strike on the
white Rook but I'm wondering firstly if
you move it or ignore that threat
because it's all about that white Pawn
uh maybe you can just take that black
Rook on G8 maybe you just move that
white Rook if you don't want to
calculate now it's getting tricky for
Vincent with 50 seconds because he has
so many tempting options um multiple
strong candidate moves here how easy do
you think it is Robert the evaluation
bar has gone Sky High but Vincent
doesn't know that he's still got to be
accurate so he calculated his way
through it he takes the Rook on G if
Knight takes a rook on A3 this Knight
will come back to F6 and the problem for
the black king it's in a smothered
Checkmate like position so this Pawn on
E6 it will not be able to leave
otherwise there'll be a back rank
problem so uh it's quite straightforward
Vincent he double checked triple checked
and now he's figured out that this is
going to be his game for the taking
because his D Pawn or his E Pawn if it
captures on E6 will be a passer that
black can hardly
stop that is brutal just the calmness to
take that rook and allow your own Rook
to beautiful but then Retreat your White
Knight Knight F6 there would
be just chef's kiss to that one that is
really nicely spotted uh by Vincent ker
and you can tell his body language
Vincent on the camera super calm Levon
as well Panic setting in he knows that
this game is going
to take this Knight back I guess you can
play Rook takes Knight then the white
Rook saves itself I guess you go to the
D3 Square protect your pawn and it's
simple mathematics again Rook against
Knight your uper material and on such an
open board clearly the Rooks will beat
here it's a matter of time it looks like
maybe resignation in the next few turns
just one or two more accurate moves and
Vincent has got this in the bag if I'm
leavon I just try to play quickly
Knights are tricky pieces especially
when you get into bullet time controls
players Miss Forks all the time it
happens every Saturday in bullet braw
I've seen it firsthand so right now for
leavon he's just trying to figure out
can he get any
uh hope can he play something that
forces Vincent to find an only line the
answer doesn't seem to be yes it looks
too straightforward for Vincent and I
think leavon he's just trying to come to
terms with the fact that this will be
his first deficit all of today remember
he won game two in their grand final
match and then Vincent was able to
strike back in the next game but leavon
he was the one who seemed to have the
upper hand and now it looks like he's
going to Trail and it's a two game match
he'll only have one one more to strike
back and uh it's always always tough
when things go against you you're riding
on a high ofen armag get Victory and
then suddenly this happens um so yeah
Levon he'll need to show all of his
class all of his experience to come back
shaking his head now the first giveaway
the poker face has disappeared but
there's nothing to be done he's just got
to choose his own uh fate here Rook to
D3 has predicted and that black knight
no chance it competes against the white
Rooks um well he's despondent here
Robert I think we'll see him just end
this game very shortly Rook takes Pawn
now on E6 looks like a freebie and black
knight can run jump all at once it's on
the wrong flank on the wrong side of the
board Vincent very professional though
using all of his 30 seconds uh just a
quick update for everyone in the other
game still dead level end game this is
where the blood will be spilled back to
D2 he's going with this Knight Knights
are are such annoying pieces and he
takes on A4 instead a D6 D7 would have
been my first thought but I guess the
black king is just in time to run on
over and you can't deliver The Knockout
just yet so in said I love this from
Vincent he doesn't push his pass Pawn he
takes a pawn well he's got his choice H7
and A7 and then he can push his pass
Pawn later while he has created two more
of his
own doing everything right but Levon
still fighting 15 seconds against 5
Seconds
how does he get that dewn through might
as well start grabbing some pawns and um
okay he does indeed but this counter
play you could see someone getting
nervous here um those bullet brw words
Robert running through my mind now be
careful the pawns are running but Pawn
to D7 it does look like white is ahead
in the race three seconds Le on aronian
drops his King back and there we go
Harry the hwn to the rescue the hn is
going to run so quickly up the board but
the Knight still jumping Robert I can
still see this turning Vincent's making
moves with two three seconds left but
look at this he froze both of the pawns
that was a fantastic decision from him
now he's just going to throw his H Pawn
off the board dump under a rook Retreat
back to D1 and eventually H7 h8 becomes
the Game ending threat and he plays Rook
C8 wow he took care of
business he really really nailed it down
when it mattered and he walked into a
fork here but white makes a new Queen uh
Pawns of the Sol of chess that is
touchdown and Vincent takes the win with
white so impressive Robert and he's way
too modest to celebrate but I think
internally Vincent was jumping for joy
he wins game one against leavon ronian
now we have just the other game in
division three that match it's the first
game of the reset and Alexis SRA with
the black pieces it looks like he is the
better position of the two with the more
active rook and actually moves her
trickling into very quickly it's not
just better it's winning for
SRA wow Lincoln you miss it that
happened so fast that turnaround and
looked like gisik had everything under
control but look at him on the camera
he's devastated he lost two pawns and
this again it's just a matter of
connecting those pawns black is simply
winning matter of technique as they say
Robert this is Elementary stuff but oh
went went South so quickly Griff's clock
playing the biggest role he was on 5
seconds for the last 30 moves and
eventually he slipped up and two extra
pawns the king is going to be shielded
from checks this Rook at any moment can
slide around and go after this right now
in fact and this is the moment Rook H3
can take on H4 but why grab more pawns
push your passers there's nothing that
the white king can do to stop it all
right he took my initial advice David
but I don't think he needs that H4 Pawn
to win the
game three pass pawns is a pretty sight
and why not grab the opponent's
remaining counterplay there the black
king is going to sit happily behind it
F7 Pawn there we go no more checks and
now you just push P to G3 s wins and the
youngsters have struck
back
wow right after those veteran players
they were able to send this into a grand
final reset you saw it on gish's face he
was kind of disgusted with the end game
that he had it was even he was the one
with the better position but Alexis SRA
he's not going to lose a game without a
huge fight and he brought the fight to
kuk came back won the end game so we see
the youngsters Vincent kimer in division
2 Alexis s in division three they Lead 1
nil and David it's a best of two time
there is not much remaining it's Last
Chance Saloon for the two players who
went down to defeat and uh again it's a
roller coaster of emotions Robert these
I mean this format it's so exciting it
puts the players through everything they
have to recover they have to pick
themselves up and learning how to win in
these must-win situations is uh yeah
it's the toughest thing but they've been
there before this is where experience
counts they're still capable and uh the
younger players have to decide their
strategy now and Vincent will he just
try to lock it down play solid but
playing for a draw risk involved there
as well you don't want to be too
negative um all the emotions he's going
through right now on the camera as we
build up to what could be the final game
of both
div and Vincent ker he's been on the
world's biggest stages with the lead
against one of the best players if not
the best player on the planet remember
the 2023 World Cup Vincent beat Magnus
Carlson in the first game and then the
second game he had a chance to just find
a tactic and make sure that Magnus had
no winning chances of his own he
overlooked it and then Magnus struck and
then unfortunately Magnus kept on
striking and won the entire event so
that's not unfortunate it's just
unfortunate for Vincent as he tries to
remove those memories from the Forefront
of his brain and say hey I'm up a point
this is exactly where I want to be yeah
and those are tough experiences you
mentioned that one at the World Cup
Vincent's going to learn from them
though and he'll adapt his mindset he'll
always be ready to pounce he won't trust
the opponent now if they Blended like
Magnus did in that game H so Vincent
yeah this is a big big moment he'll
start uh with black so it's not going to
be easy Leon's going to throw everything
him but uh Robert predictions will
either of the two players come back will
we see more chess Armageddon
today I think that leavon is in some
serious trouble I think GIS shook uh you
know he has the black pieces in game two
that's not going to help his go I think
no no more Armageddon David are you
going to disagree um I'll disagree
because I love chess and I want to see
the uh experienced players come back um
Armageddon would be a fitting way to
separate these great warriors but in the
meantime leevon not looking too
optimistic on the camera but he employs
the Italian game yet again Robert and uh
yeah take it away what do you think of
uh this third uh appearance of this
opening it feels like I'm receiving an
opening lesson from these two because
leavon aronian keeps trotting out the
Italian game and Vincent kimer he
Retreats his Bishop back to A7 so that
means B4 or D4 don't come with a Tempo
against a bishop on C5 so Vincent I
think he learned his lesson from that
earlier contest where leavon was able to
put some serious pressure on him open
some files take over the seventh rank V
he wants to be stable but if I'm also
being honest that sometimes especially
for younger players who don't have as
much experience they think that in order
to secure the draw they have to quote
unquote play for a draw and that means
you're not always playing objectively so
for Vincent kimer solid game with the
black pieces simply pushing pawns
developing castling I can't fault a
single decision that he's made and for
leavon Ronin he's going back to the
tried and true plan he brings his Knight
out to D2 his Knight will wrap back
around to F1 his Knight then will
venture forward to G3 or we could see a
repeat of that earlier game where that
Knight somehow made its way to G4 before
it was captured so it's vinage kimer on
the move
one common idea in this position in fact
it's been essayed by leavon himself in
some fabulous games is Knight to G4 to
put immediate pressure on the F2 pawn
and the real Point behind this isn't
going for a one move tactic white will
not Overlook that it's that black often
wants to put the king in the corner and
push the pawn to F5 so that's a riskier
variation if Vincent hadn't won the
first game perhaps he would have gone
down that line but instead we see that
Vincent continues to play solidly I
expect the bishop to come out to E6
offering the trade I think that leavon
he can confidently bring his Knight back
out to G3 as he did earlier uh in
today's action he can also Retreat his
Bishop we saw players choosing that
option to escape any trades but for lvon
he's going to need to take risk you
can't just play this cly and patiently
because as it stands the position isn't
much in it at least not for now though
there are double pawns and perhaps long
term that could be something that white
goes after Queen B3 is always meant by
Queen C8 so that's not immediately an
issue but David as we you know dive into
this position and you look at how the
opening stage is gone what do you make
of it do you think that Vincent is the
least bit unhappy with his current
position I think he's fine with it uh
yes the black porn structure is messier
than my office after spilling my drink
but uh other than the double black e
ones I think he's okay with it I mean
he's got experience here I actually sat
next to Vincent at the European Team
Championships a few months ago where he
played a couple of games with the
structure and uh he defended very ably
there so um yeah interesting start to
this game very quiet and uh Robert as
you mentioned we're learning a lot about
the Italian the kind of Maneuvers the
placement it's I mean third Italian but
the third totally different type of
structure position that we're being
treated to so um yeah this is going to
simmer for a long time I feel and uh
yeah it's just about whether Vincent's
nerves hold up long term um yeah Leon on
the camera I've got to say this is the
most negative body language I've seen
from him for a long long time um maybe
just not enjoying this third Italian as
much as he was the previous
two and these are long days for the
Players let's you know not Overlook how
much work they are putting in because
because they prepare for their matches
they end up playing you know four rapid
games then an armagedon fifth game and
now into a a grand final reset these are
not easy days for these top players sure
they've played classical chess and
played eight hour games so they know
what it's like but so many different
positions swirling in their head it's
not simple to just forget about what's
just transpired and now focus on your
next steps but I think it's clear from
the white perspective the next steps are
about putting pressure on some of
Black's loose Pawns in the position and
so for Vincent the question becomes how
do you actually defend all of your
weaknesses a move like Rook to B8 does
not look particularly appealing but
maybe David it's necessary yeah it might
well be necessary and um as we've uh
kind of shown in previous games
sometimes you have to just take the
passive route you just have to defend
something um I see Queen to D6 as well
just uh setting a nice little trap don't
take my Pawn on B7 please don't but then
if you do Rook F2 B8 traps Her Majesty
there um so yeah there are kind of
creative ways to defend things and there
we go it's actually on the board Queen
to D6 um but yeah Rook to B8 as well um
yeah and white just continues to line up
I've jokingly Robert mentioned the kind
of age difference the battle of the
generations but yeah such a long day
guaranteed that the players are feeling
it especially Levon and uh Sasha Gish
right now um but okay maximum pressure
here 3 minutes up
Levon I think I am actually going to say
I'm going to back my uh prediction I'm
gonna say Armageddon in this one I just
have a feeling um that Levon will ask a
question or two Vincent might get
nervous it's the type of position it's
really hard to find easy natural moves
and uh we might get treated who knows to
more chess okay well leavon he loves rap
He loves Jazz he loves improvising but
how is he going to improvise in this
game I'm just looking at the setup it's
very solid but then I my eyes go off the
board to the clock nine plus minutes for
leavon and a huge decision there from
Vincent he pushes his Pawn forward that
makes the queen on B3 a bit happier
because it stares into Black's position
what do you make of this latest decision
sure Pawn traits can happen on doubling
Black's pawns but I feel like now we are
seeing some imbalances yeah we
definitely see imbalances and this
really is reminiscent of what Vincent
did a couple of well I say a couple of
games ago earlier in the day at least in
the Italian he pushed a pawn to D4 he
locked it up cut the board in half we
described it as and uh ultimately yeah
things didn't go his way so um okay a
trade of Pawns it was based on concrete
reasons he just wanted to UND double
he's kind of done that by force the
black e pawns no longer as much of an I
saw as they were earlier but um yeah
he's fixed the structure now the white
Rooks if assuming they get blocked on
the eile they might just switch over to
the C file a semi-open line has appeared
over there and uh hence why Vincent's
trying to fight on the other flank the
Black Knight now coming into F4 I can
see why he's done this Robert um it's
very appealing at least he has a clickup
plan now unlike maybe two moves ago but
uh yeah long term it's very very
committal and um yeah for someone with
commitment issues like me it's I'm not
sure I would play D4 but uh yeah it's
definitely uh kind of trying to solve
Black's Problems by Brute Force but and
as chess players we like to associate to
known positions isn't this a bit
familiar doesn't this remind you of the
Armageddon game where leavon sacrificed
a rook for a knight on F3 to expose his
opponent's king Rook takes F3 is
something that I would be scared of I'm
looking at this position I was I mean
Rook takes F3 for me is automatic in
bullet but this is a move that is
responsible you are going to give a rook
for a knight and this B7 Pawn is under
attack later so can you just go straight
on for your attack I'm not so sure this
requires calculation Robert I think Rook
takes F3 would be a master stroke if not
for the fact that white would ignore it
and take on B7 first and he's played it
but Queen takes B7 hits the rook in the
corner hits the Knight yes you are a
knight down temporarily with white but
you Counterattack and Black's Queen side
just collapses Leon ronian the fact he's
paused May kind of means indicates that
he's calculating this but wow the most
confusing thing for me Robert here the
evaluation bar still in the center
Black's just sacrificed a rook for
Knight controversial stuff Black's two
Rooks are both hanging Black's Knight is
hanging and it's equal explain this how
is this level Vincent with under five
minutes has to calculate his way through
this total mess and apparently black has
multiple moods because we usually see
that blue arrow appear telling us when
there is just one decision so because I
know there are multiple I'm just going
to suggest something things Knight uh B4
can I attack your Rook because if you
take this rook in the corner my Rook
slides back but I'm more like concerned
if you take this Rook first because then
the rook in the corner is still under
attack so I just don't see the exact end
point and I'm I'm worried now that black
you know bit off more than he could chew
because he's not getting his material
back you make get some pressure against
the white king but to be down material
that weighs on the mind it really does
and uh as well as the computer's
evaluation I must say the bit that's
tripping me up here why did Vincent take
on F3 surely he examined Queen takes B7
and had an idea had an answer prepared
up his sleeve but white take on F3 and
then pause uh unless it wasn't on his
radar at all Robert do you think he's
missed something just a long think
suddenly after he being the one to
choose going in for this concrete uh
Jungle of uh variations um there's ideas
like Pawn to E5 for white you can throw
in at any moment just uh kind of use the
White Queen on the diagonal back to take
a rook on F3 there's I mean it's just
pure chaos and Vincent being four
minutes down on the clock here is going
to be extremely significant um I think
even if he finds the best move whether
that's Knight B4 or another um I think
he's in for some trouble now um this is
a Levon type of position talking about
Styles it's messy Dynamic right up his
Street and the evaluation bar means
nothing here neither player knows
there's so much chaos happening I
mentioned leavon Rowan's affinity for
rap and Jazz he also loves traditional
classical stuff classical music and
older movies so in this type of position
he's heading us back to the Romantic Era
let's give up a night on one side let's
go for Attack on the other and vinit
plays night to before and the evaluation
doesn't change so my question David is
if I take this Rook on F3 the the
biggest question of all is what is
Black's followup because Knight takes
Rook Queen takes other Rook with check
there comes the exclamation point I
guess with more depth the engine
realizes that this is a great move and
perhaps the only move that kept the Evar
not just in Black's favor but remotely
near the center Dave what's the followup
here I guess the black Rook is hit you
have to move it or defend it um Rook to
f8 comes to mind but I really don't like
the idea of wow Queen to f8 blue arrow I
was about to say I don't like the idea
of allowing white to play E5 hit the
queen with Tempo so get her out the way
uh she's a really agile piece she's been
doing a Pilates she's Queen to f8 she's
going to hit F3 defend A8 defend B4
multi-purpose piece and uh the Black
Knight also really annoying to deal with
this hit on the white Rook but it's not
obvious Robert this blue arrow move
Queen to f8 I'm going to say that's
difficult for any
human extraordinarily difficult and you
see that Vincent is dro droing to below
two minutes on the he found it he just
played Queen to f8 and this might have
been process of elimination but it is a
brilliant Retreat it didn't get the two
exclamation points just one so I can
take care of that um I see what's
Happening Here There is a retreat that
defends a rook in the corner but also it
attacks so I'm going to give it these
exclamation points it's got three in
fact but in all seriousness this is such
a tremendous retreating move look at
this queen is doing protecting The Rook
protecting the Knight attacking this
loose pawn and you may find the white
king in a checkmating net this is just a
fantastic fantastic retreating move from
Vincent kyber wow yeah just incredible
retreating is difficult at the best of
times especially if you've sacrificed
something to take a timeout to just
calmly Retreat the queen and now you're
because you're defending everything
you're holding the fort you have the
luxury of time next move I'm assuming
white saves his Rook Levon White's Rook
on C2 is attacked the pawn on D3 is
attacked the most natural move would be
Rook to D D2 but then the other Black
Knight could come in and wow he goes
aggressive Rook takes C7 here and I mean
all bets are off Robert I'm failing to
predict every single move it feels like
at this point but suddenly the White
Queen is hit and the pawn is dropping is
this the start of the domino effect is
White's position collapsing as well my
head is on a swivel I'm looking left I'm
looking right I'm trying to figure out
is it F2 and F3 that are a problem is
that this Rook on B8 it's loose so the
queen has to stay at attached to it is
at the time where leavon has about six
minutes and Vincent is down under
two even approximately get out of here
this is just an absolute mess and for
Vincent kimer it's the $15,000 for
winning the division it's also that spot
that coveted spot in division one in the
second leg he wants that more than
anything and he also wants his F3 pawn
more than anything because he's teaming
up against it I don't know what white
should do next but I do see that black
has compensation for the sacrifice
material yeah huge compensation if white
is careless we've seen it before
multiple times actually in this match if
the knights start jumping this could
just end in Checkmate White's King is in
the firing line purely because of the
weak Pawn structure and um yeah I agree
with this feature chat climate is so
good but also look now below our
boards I've got to say Robert 98 and 99%
accuracy in such a wild game that is a
real kind of uh indicator of how inform
both of these players are right now 98
99% it's possible if you have great
opening preparation if it's maybe a kind
of position where the difference between
move one and move five isn't so great
but here they're finding only moves
Vincent's been walking a narrow tight
RPP yet he's still up at 99% this is
another level Knight E5 brilliant move
but he has to back it up now Rook to C1
how does he continue There is a threat
Queen takes B8 would simplify the
equation here in White's favor so he has
to be careful he has to avoid the
opponent's
ideas and how do you avoid it do you
bring your king off the last rank do
Scurry on over with your Rook to one of
these squares and David what I've always
found fascinating is that when you
analyze games and you think there's no
difference in where you move a piece and
then the end just one is losing and one
is winning for some unknown reason and
we see an only move now for White Knight
to G3 not Knight D2 to protect your
loose Pawn instead Knight KN to G3
offering a a trade of knights excuse me
not queens and there actually are some
threats in the position if the Knight on
H5 where to go Rook takes G7 check
because the black queen is tied to too
many pieces at the same time it's
overloaded that's a concept that
everybody uh should look up or study if
you already know it but Knight G3 this
is trying to trade off one of Black's
most important attackers and
Defenders yeah I think uh actually the
more I look at it very findable move
this one's logical you need to bring a
piece to defend but also as you
mentioned Robert Counterattack remove
Black's Defender um but calculation of
course required I'm assuming black plays
Knight takes F3 in that position check
uh the pawn will be hanging and then
it's like a one in three lucky dip the
white king can choose one of three
different squares you might get M if you
step to the wrong one and uh that's why
Levon oron and he's trying to delve into
that Forest of complications yeah I mean
the players in their mind we've all been
there this type of position no
evaluation but they have no idea they
think they're doing well they might
think they're in trouble but ultimately
it's just looking for good moves
surviving preventing the opponent's
threats so Knight G3 I think it's going
to be played but this is only the
beginning RIT it is and this arrow is
only the beginning because it tells us
that this is White's only move to keep
equality and black may have an only move
on his end to keep equality and it can
continue in this manner so that is why
Dave and I are so impressed with the
accuracy and just as I'm about to say
that a mistake from leavon that was
clear he put his Queen on a square the
engine immediately hated it and then the
queen went to F6 but the engine was down
to like minus three and a half now back
to minus two ignore the evaluation it's
helping us know that black actually is
doing well but the players they don't
know it D dcent Vincent is down to just
a minute and change on the clock and so
David if he is not accurate here and he
allows the white king to escape then
Lavan is going to have that extra
material wow now the bar has gone crazy
and there are so many tempting moves
let's do some quick counting though
black has got three attackers the queen
and the two black knights three
attackers white I'm going to say only
two Defenders the White Queen and Rooks
cut off on the wrong side of the board
so where is the killer blow um I'm
looking at mating patterns Knight G5 I
actually wanted to highlight that
earlier uh that would have come into
play in Another variation that sets up a
nasty three move Checkmate idea of the
black queen coming down to the F3 Square
replacing the Knight the Black Knight
jumping in and some uh checks leading to
mate but is there anything better that's
the question the computer says it's
totally busted for white here we said it
there's going to be a turnaround Robert
do you see any other tempting attacking
ideas Vincent 26 seconds he drops his
Knight back the other
way what a move he just retreating he's
giving up his Knight seemingly for free
but it's because he's going to land his
Queen F3 with check and then recapture
this Knight on F3 that's not the end of
the story there are all sorts of ideas
going against the black king but Vincent
has calculated them all 26 seconds on
his clock but a winning objectively a
winning Advantage according to the
engine he's just playing with purpose
every single turn has been a good choice
from Vincent yeah we have to remember
he's the exchange down he's two points
down but it's about the quality of the
pieces Black's pieces so strong Black's
rookie even doing a great job on the
other side of the board the Deep Pawn
watch out for that to run I mean if
white survives that's that's the first
question Lon suddenly I don't think he
realizes how bad his position is
understandably it's just a total mess in
his eyes but uh it's going to Dawn on
him now um in a must-win situation that
I think at the very minimum Robert whes
King is so open that Vinson will be able
to bail out with Perpetual check if
necessary um but yeah of course he'll
want to win the game if he can Queen to
F3 is just Unstoppable no way to prevent
that move I think he just has to bite
the bullet take that Black Knight on H5
and say prove it mate Checkmate me and
uh Vincent will try to do so of course
what a game though it's been so far and
I love that feature chat yes leevon has
the aline's gun the two Rooks and queen
lined up but unfortunately on the wrong
side of the board and normally that has
to stare at something it's staring at
nothing right the C8 square is not
valuable so whes pieces they're not
operating on squares and files that you
need them to be if you could bring this
Rook to the seventh rank somehow then
you'd start feeling better about your
chances going after the black king so we
see a capture on H5 quickly Vincent
steals back this Knight and now all of a
sudden Knight F3 check Queen G4 check
there all sorts of issues for the white
King David no defenders in front of it
zero Defenders zero protection the porn
shelter has been Stripped Away all at
the cost of just a rook for night
um yeah Knights F3 looks like a killer I
don't even see any moves here Robert
like everything I want to play it walks
into a KN for or Knight check um at the
very minimum as well Black's Rook can
come over to G8 to protect while the
black queen and Knight wreck havoc
together looks like Vincent is about to
win um in the other match though Robert
it looks like s in control um grishuk
looks devastated he's a porn down
grishuk with black s is he going to take
division
three it looks to be the case the
evaluation bar is going up up and away
and it's getting away from grishuk
although you know it keeps going on to
seesaw the problem for grishuk is he
needs to win so you can repeat moves if
you're s to win division three and grook
yeah he's in trouble Let's uh it's hard
to choose either game David because
Leon's in trouble G's in trouble it
looks like the youngsters are going to
come out on top yeah the younger
generation
just uh showing that extra energy in
this Marathon battle and uh let's go
back to this game in division 2 oh so
much at stake Vincent about to secure
his place in division one next time but
there's a mate threat watch out for
quinx G7 Checkmate he guards and he
attacks at the same time the white king
walking oh feels like into trouble the
Black Knight can come into D3 there we
go threatening Checkmate in one himself
Rook takes F2 is massive threat the
white Rook as well also hanging Robert
this might be over there we go Vincy K
wins division two and you see Vincent
finally he his emotions they're on his
face he is very happy because he's won
$15,000 he's won the Lion Share of the
tour points in the second division and
he's guaranteed a slot in the next
events division one so congratulations
to Vincent kimer he outlasted leavon Ron
who was able to send the match to a
grand final reset but he just couldn't
get it going in the best of two match
David what a performance from Vincent
and it looks like a great performance
from Alexis S as well yeah welld
deserved Vincent ker and alexe here look
at that deflection tactic taking a pawn
with Czech throwing away the white Rook
because the black Rook is now undefended
and he can force a draw here if he wants
with a bunch of checks grishuk knows 5
seconds on his clock that he is not
going to survive this game uh White is
objectively winning white is after all a
porn up protected pass Pawn as well that
beautiful white ewn can run down the
board sooner uh rather than later but uh
ultimately yeah black I don't think he's
going to save this game Robert maybe
Sano will choose to bail out with a draw
now and he trades Queens super safe
Choice as long as you don't blunder a
knight Fork there's no way for Alexis
serona to lose this game he can make
simple moves bring his King up the board
he can push his ewn at any moment so for
Alexi he doesn't need to win but he's
getting the job done barring some kind
of wild blunder that I don't even know
how to make work so it looks done it
looks done and uh there we go Vin yeah
Gish looks done as well he made that
last move with under one second left the
ewn steps forward we're going to see a
resignation there we go s takes division
three Alexis s he dropped the first
match of today's action against
Alexander gruk but he was not to be
deterred it was a slip it was a blip it
was momentary but Alexa Ser he goes down
in the history books he wins division
three of the 2024 ches Masters so David
the youngsters after being pushed to a
reset they hit the reset button and they
came back fresh both of them winning
2-n yeah a tale of two halves the first
match it was very much the experienced
players showing all of their cunning and
their resolve But ultimately ah Vincent
and S we can't we can't fault them they
were the favorites at the beginning of
the day Robert they had two lives and
yes they lost one of them but ultimately
they survived I think uh on the balance
of things very welld deserved they were
the most consistent players of their
respective divisions throughout this
last week and it goes to show that
you're coming into the final day with
two lives rather than one that does make
you the favorite because wi these
players they're about equivalent in
strength you can lose one match but to
win two matches in a row it's so
challenging against these Superstars so
viek kimer wins division two we'll see
him in division one the next time around
and Alexa SRA he wins in division three
he jumps the playin tournament he will
go straight to the placement and maybe
we will also see him in division one the
next time around but David why don't you
take us through the critical moments
because what looks like a a LPS side
affair on paper that's not always the
case when you dive in to the board and
the tactics yeah uh the result never
tells the full story in chess there's
always so much bubbling under the
surface uh whether it's what the players
are calculating whether it's missed
opportunities and this was a tale of
missed opportunities for Alexander
grishuk here with white SRA he's just
Advanced his King to F2 the black queen
is creating real nuisance from behind
there's ideas of going behind hitting
this bishop and uh this Black Knight is
super strong but Gish he lost momentum
here he took this pawn and after the
recaptures he missed a winning move a
winning opportunity to strike back he
moved his Queen away back to G5
retreating losing momentum and
ultimately losing this game but if he
had spotted the cunning Knight to B2 uh
sorry in this position he would have
turned things immediately Knight to
tricky pieces that's been the theme of
today and look at this the black queen
is hit but you cannot take her if you
take the queen you walk into this Fork
if you move the White Queen however then
you walk into yet another fork in this
position Queen to E3 or queen to D2 for
example Queen takes rook and another KN
Fork wins the game grishuk one move he
blinked he missed it and ultimately was
punished wow you know I have a LoveHate
relationship with game review I love
seeing tactics like that but I hate when
they tell me that I miss these beautiful
tactics that could have saved the day
and that would have sent this second
match to Armageddon but no Armageddon in
the Grand Final reset we saw Vincent
kimer take division 2 we saw Alex X take
division 3 and we'll be joined by
Vincent kimer on the flip side of this
break don't go anywhere this is your
2024 Chess Masters be back with Vincent
in just a
[Music]
few
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially
exciting be sure to watch all the games
on the live stream at chess.com and on
our freestyle d.com website from
February 9th to 16 2024 at the first
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
luxurious weisson House Resort
experience the thrill and fascination of
Chess in a completely new
light the Chess World Championship has
been a prestigious title for well over a
hundred years but often times the prize
money was lackluster chess in the 19th
century developed without an
international governing body World
Championships were negotiated between
players with Challengers expected to
raise large enough Stakes to entice a
title holder to compete the first
official World Championship in 1886 had
a substantial prize purse fitting for an
inaugural event subsequent championship
ship failed to generate substantial
purses it would take 35 years for the
world championship's prize purse to
surpass the amount raay for the first
championship something magical happened
in chess a new Challenger from the
United States pierced the Iron Curtain
and threatened to end Soviet dominance
of the
sport Bobby fiser won the canidates
matches in 1971 earning him the right to
play spasy for the world title fiser was
different than other play players of the
time he didn't just want to be the best
player or the most dominant or even the
most famous he wanted to be
paid fiser grew up in abject poverty in
Brooklyn New York and was highly
motivated by money and earning what he
believed chess players were worth the
story lines were interesting and
diverse USA versus the
USSR West versus East capitalism versus
communism the world was ready to see
these two superpowers battle it out on
the chest
table fiser demands continue to impact
almost every variable of the event
including the location the chess board
and pieces and of course the prize purse
fiser even had the audacity to demand a
share of the ticket sales and broadcast
royalties for the
players at one point it looked like the
event might not even
happen Fisher claimed the prize money
was too low despite it already being the
highest in
history Fisher's calculated moves paid
off when a wealthy business owner
doubled the prize purse raising it to
$250,000 or $1.7 million today Fischer
and spasy shared a prize purse bigger
than all the previous World Championship
prizes
combined after their match Boris sposi
stated to the Press how grateful he was
for Bobby fer and how the money from
this event was going to change his life
Bobby fiser single-handedly raised the
profile and catapulted chess into a
mainstream sport followed by millions of
people fiser had ensured that not only
he and spasy but every World
Championship competitor after them
earned a deserving
[Music]
prize
he
[Music]
a hello everyone and welcome back we're
joined by the winner of division 2
Vincent kimer congratulations Vincent uh
really dramatic uh match today what are
your initial
Impressions yeah I mean I lost this
pretty bad game in the second round of
the first match and then I as I had
prepared some kind of very aggressive
idea with white in case I needed it
which I then used in game three to
equalize the match and I think then in
the Sumer get on he just played an
extremely good game like I didn't really
even after the game I checked I didn't
really find any mistakes and he was also
playing quickly which is of course
extremely bad if you need to win the
game so I think like he just played an
extremely good armagedon and then the
second the reset match yeah I think both
games went well I mean the second game
at some point I thought I had blundered
because like Rook F3 Queen B7 the ideas
I had at first didn't work but I think
in general then after I found this of
night before Queen f8 again I was kind
of confident that it might actually work
but yeah no idea I will have to check
with an engine
afterwards now we were impressed and uh
you had very high accuracy accuracy
levels according to what we could see in
that game so um I mean you've been
playing a lot of tournaments recently
Vincent you played in uh uh yeah you've
played multiple and you're about to play
in uh the freestyle goat challenge as
well how do you feel your form is you've
played a lot of Chess this
week yeah I mean I think this is clearly
the best result I've ever had in the
Champions Chester and I also felt that I
playing at least
okay uh of course you know there always
up and downs Bad Games blunders it's
online rapid yeah and also quite fast
Rapid Control it can happen but in
general I was feeling that I'm in a
rather good shape but I think what's
good about the format here is that also
it really promotes Fighting Chess and
also Inon house we will have no opening
Theory as it is chess 960 so I think
that's kind of a good preparation
already and of course also there will be
extremely strong players so I think I
will see level one again
soon and uh you mentioned the Champions
chess tour encouraging Fighting Chess
how do you feel about the double
elimination format which came into play
today yeah I mean I think if you lose
one match then you're happy if you win
all matches you're not very happy but in
general I think it's good in the sense
that you get some chance yeah sometimes
it can happen that basically you lose
the match due to one bad game and I feel
at some point it's actually better to
have this option of saying okay you know
I played one bad match but still I have
the chance to come back and also as we
saw in the final today like the player
who won all matches up to the final has
an advantage so I think it's very fair
MH and uh you mentioned that Levon
played a great Armageddon game how tough
was it for you to reset mentally after
that uh for the second
match surprisingly not that hard like I
was just because this armagon you know I
already realized after the first 15 20
moves that it's going to be extremely
difficult like I mean Levon there's a
reason why he was numbered to behind
Magnus for so long 28 35 whatever yeah
so like class and feeling for chess he
has more than enough for sure yeah so
only chance is to like okay trick him in
some kind of way so then when he got to
his kind of nice position and just play
by hand the classy good moves F quickly
then it's really hard so I was just
thinking okay yeah I lost this match I
think I had to blame myself for losing
the second game and then yeah I was
trying to do my best with white and I
also what was helping that we
immediately got a fighting position but
I think a quite good one like as soon as
I got to push D5 I was quite confident
that my position should be much better
and then it was easy to play and I think
that's also not the kind of position he
likes because like I think one of the
main weaknesses for him in rid is that
basically when he he gets low on time he
starts his level drops quite a lot so of
course getting to a complicated position
where he has to think a lot helps me and
I think that's also what the second game
then the first game went quite well in
the reset match MH it's interesting to
hear that you're already kind of
planning you know your opponent's
strengths weaknesses uh beforehand uh
did you feel that you were the underdog
at any point today after for example the
first match or were you always quite
confident that you'd get your
chances I mean what means confident yeah
like playing against loveon you hardly
can consider yourself a favorite
especially I mean after losing the first
match I mean before at least I can say
okay I only have to win one of two
matches he has to win both so of course
that's a quite big Advantage but I mean
after losing the first one also
psychologically he's like happy he feels
that yeah actually now he has a chance
when before it was more like he has to
rely on me making a mistake so yeah I
mean I was not feeling that I have no
chance but of course I was feeling that
okay now it's like really time to show
my best chest otherwise I will lose this
fight today yeah and uh we do have some
questions from our chat Vincent uh so
John Fe asks do you train to avoid
getting nervous in these must-win or
must draw
situations I don't know a single chance
player that doesn't get nervous in those
situations I mean that's I think kind of
it's also necessary to be honest because
it's like you need some kind of extra
focus and concentration of course you
need to train not to get overx Ed or
like play way too quickly way too slowly
to kind of get stuck on this but I think
if you learn how to use like some kind
of nervousness it's actually helpful
even fully agreed and uh Elias pran asks
how is it possible to play so accurately
with time trouble added to the
mix yeah I think it really depends on
the position like if you refer to the
second game of the reset match I think
it was simply that before I had to make
the tough decisions and after making
those decisions the rest of the moves
come kind of naturally like then it
already make sense what I am doing my
pieces are correctly and then it's easy
to play with seconds I wouldn't consider
myself like a great player with seconds
but if you if I get like a normal
position and where it's logical the good
moves just work then it's not that
difficult to play also with
seconds true that's the dream and um
looking ahead you've now qualified for
division one uh what are you uh most
excited about uh for that one yeah I
mean it's my first time playing division
one like and those plays last time I
finished like nin twice I think so I
never got the chance even to play for
division one last year now wesle kicked
me out of that race so I'm very happy to
like no finally get my division one and
of course I will give my very best and
we will see what
happens okay nice one Vincent and last
question for me uh will you be watching
Magnus against alaza tomorrow and if so
what's your your
prediction I will try to watch but I
think I'll be in a train so I'm not sure
how good the connection will be but yeah
predictions are very tough I think like
in my opinion it's always yeah like if
Magnus shows up with 100% in his best
player it's hard for me to imagine that
someone will beat him especially since
also ARA is the one who needs to win
both matches but you know these matches
have their own kind of strategy and
their own moments and their own Dynamic
so I think everything's possible
and uh Vincent kimer congratulations on
winning division 2 of the ches Masters
and best of luck at the freestyle goat
challenge we'll all be cheering for you
thank you very much
cheers and that was Vincent kimer your
division 2 champion in the chville
Masters you heard him alongside David he
gave his thoughts he also gave some
predictions for what might happen
division one but what needs no
prediction is the player that will join
some of the others in division one the
next time around Vincent kimer he wins
the money $15,000 he wins the tour
points and he wins that coveted spot
David he will be in division one the
next time yeah he's earned his place
Robert and I think we're all looking
forward to seeing how he fares he
mentioned it's his first division one of
the Champions chess tour I mean that
slipped past my radar because he's such
a strong player it feels like he's
already established and um yeah I mean
his chess career it looks so bright for
him I wouldn't be surprised if he gets
to the business end of division one next
time the way he played today if he can
maintain that form then uh yeah he's
going to be one to watch it's one of the
brightest stars on the chess scene just
such a talent was so humble he kind of
went under the radar for a while he was
finishing up his schooling and now that
he's done with that he seems to be
focused on chess once more and he's
about to travel to that freestyle goat
challenge where he'll face off against
Magnus and the others but vinent he took
down division two we also watched the
final in division 3 and division 3 is
packed with star power with talented
players left and right you started with
32 people and then the field was Whitted
down to just one and it's Alexis s who
won division 3 and that shouldn't come
as too much of a surprise because he
participated in division 1 in a 23
season but the way he did it he lost the
Grand Final first match to Guk and then
he won the reset 2-0 there was that one
tactic that you showed David but Alexis
s he proved that he is a tough customer
he takes down division three and it's
only the way up from here yeah he's so
consistent so impressive European
Champion European team champion rapid
Champion he's uh yeah just one to watch
and uh ultimately yes he was fighting
against gisher Mr experience there but
uh he took it and welld deserved really
uh consistent performance uh impressive
throughout
Rober super impressive play from these
two divisions just because they may not
be in the top division in this event
does not mean that we aren't seeing some
exceptional play so David and we will
see Magnus versus oliv R tomorrow in the
division one finals what take me through
your thoughts about what we just
witnessed Vincent and Alexi coming out
on top well I think a lot to learn
especially looking ahead to that Magnus
against ala final after all that too
will also be a generational Clash you
will also see one player with two lives
versus one what we learned today is that
anything's possible if the player even
in a mus situation brings their best
game they can fight back but we also
learned it's a marathon it's so tough to
keep a high level throughout such a long
day so ultimately s ker congratulations
fja has to do that tomorrow it's not
going to be easy but he's the younger
player and he should take inspiration
from
today and ala seemed like he was happy
to have this opportunity after all he
had to make his way back through the
losers bracket so today's action it's
done for we saw Vincent kimer eliminate
leavon Ronan we saw Alexis SRA win
division 3 those two players deserve a
round of applause we saw some heartbreak
we saw some upsets but tomorrow we will
see the championship match in division 1
of the chestle Masters it's Magus
Carlson it's ala FIA do not miss it
tomorrow same time same place we'll see
you
then
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
n
he